[Music]
foreign
folks welcome to be our Gridiron draft
night coverage we're here in the studio
again it's myself Michael Felder and of
course we got Mike Renner here a guy
that knows his way around the scouting
game we're going to break down rounds
four through five we're gonna hit on
every pick we're gonna try to hit on
some overall overarching Concepts as
well I want to kick it off right I want
to kick it off with kind of the
overarching concept of what have you
thought about the draft so far yeah it's
been it was interesting I thought round
one very eventful but then as we got
into day two and late day two it started
to be like kickers are coming off the
board these guys are coming off the
board the luster started to come off the
draft but I do think a lot of teams
there were some teams that had a lot of
picks in this draft whether it's the
Seahawks whether it's the Lions whether
it's the Eagles that are like franchise
defining type of drafts uh I think
though it all comes back to the
quarterback position and those three
guys we saw at the top and then will
love us into round two whoever hits on
those guys are the ones that had the
best draft what about value for hooker
that's the one that's uh I love hated
what the line Lions did on day one I
thought the value they got was just not
what you would want for the 6th and 18th
pick that they came in the draft with
but they end up getting that extra
second round pick and then giving
themselves some flexibility and had an
awesome day too I mean getting ahead and
hooker where they got them a lot of
people would have you know without the
ACL tear would have been calling this
guy a first round type of pick to get
that in the third I thought the Lions
crushed it on the second day of the
draft yeah just to recap for the lines
let the Lions ended up getting obviously
we're seeing a hint and hooker right
there just push the ball around but what
the lines end up getting round one they
get they get they go out and get Jamir
Gibbs at Pig 12. it seems like that was
a little bit High pick 18 they get Jack
Campbell that also felt very high for
the Iowa linebacker then we get pick
three we get some round two pick three
Sam La Porter we like him pick two pick
14. round two pick 14 Brian Branch okay
we like him round three pick six or
excuse me pick five they get hinden
hooker and then hooker okay we've got in
it now we've got hooker and then you
throw in Broderick Martin this is a team
that did what they needed to do in the
um in the overall their draft is a
positive right I'll just say I don't
love the value of what they got in the
first round but I love the football
players I mean that was my rb2 and my
lb2 right in this draft class I think
they're both going to be tremendous at
their respective positions they just
better hope that like a Lucas Van Ness
doesn't come and haunt them for you know
two times a year in the Green Bay
Packers uniform because that's the kind
of like that's what you passed on when
you take a running back that highly you
pass on guys you could be impact players
at valuable positions
Samir Gibb's going to be an impact
player for sure but then what they did
on day two like they just targeted guys
who are good maybe not the measurable
guys maybe not the guys who uh tick The
quote-unquote Scouting boxes but they
got Five Guys in Gibbs Campbell laporta
Branch hooker that you think are
long-term stars on your football team
here's what I'm asking because I'm gonna
tell you your heartstrings a little bit
because I heard you mention Lucas Van
Ness how do you how do you feel about
the Packers Draft Packers had a unique
one to say the least I I think Lucas Van
Ness his ceiling at the edge position is
as high as it gets in this draft class
that's like even higher than like a Will
Anderson and Tyree Wilson the guys that
went before him he has a unique physical
skill set and that's just the Packers
were a team that you're after Sean Geary
who like that's a similar mold of player
that you're kind of going for where it's
like if you hit on that guy he turns
into something special and then on day
two the double tight ends and I think
there are two unique skill sets and that
Musgrave is your vertical tight end
craft is your Yak tight end an inline
blocker to where they can see the field
at the same same time the Jane Reed one
was the one where it's like a little bit
of a reach on the board but I think he's
NFL ready for slot wide receiver and you
know there aren't a ton uh guys maybe
necessarily in that mold that have size
and can play the slot at that uh
position so weird draft but one of my
one of my as a Packers fan one of the
ones in recent years that I'm happier
about than others so I'm gonna I'm gonna
stick the same division I saw in the
chat somebody said what are the Bears
doing so they've got Darnell right in
the in round one round two they got they
got gervon Dexter round three uh excuse
me round two again Tyreke Stevenson
tyrik Stevenson we love him and then
obviously round three they get Zach
Pickens a developmental player but a
player with a super high ceiling when I
look at what the Bears are doing one
protection for protection for Justin
Fields incredibly important and then we
get two Dexter and Pickens two defensive
linemen that can be very good yeah so
they took swings right you could be
looking at this draft four years from
now and none of those guys could be on
the football team Stevenson I think
Stevenson's the same pick but Dexter
Pickens right like if they don't develop
they are not making an impact on NFL
football field they are liabilities not
an NFL football field but you're in a
position where you know you're not
winning the Super Bowl this year I think
that's pretty obvious to anyone who's a
bearish fan you'll go from number one to
a Super Bowl that quickly but it's along
that defensive line these guys have all
the tools in the world to succeed so
they're swings and you're banking on
your d-line coach you're banking on what
your coaching staff can do to develop
these guys and that's ultimately if you
don't have those positions in place to
develop Talent you're not going to be a
successful team anyways yeah so the
Saints are on the clock right now and we
look at we're looking at what they've
done so far Brian brezzy from Clemson
big defensive lineman they go out and
get Isaiah foskey and a big a big bodied
Edge player then they also go out and
they get Kendra Miller a running back I
really really like I know he's coming
off what an MCL but I like him in their
in their scheme this is a guy that I
think could be really special yeah I
don't think this is quite you know 2017
draft haul when they got what Kamara
Marshawn ladmore Ryan ramchick like the
all-timer but this is a solid draft I
think Brazil is the one that we could be
looking back on this kind of the same
way we look back when on Ryan ramchick
dropping at the end of the first round
saying how'd they let this guy fall to
this spot to this team because talent
wise he's much better than that coming
into this past year mock drafts would
have had him right behind Jalen Carter
and he falls to this spot because of the
injuries that he suffered and all that
foskey I think is their type of guy
Miller's the one in terms of like Edge
rushes The Long guys they like and then
Miller's the one where it's like could
this be a Alma Kumar's Heir Apparent
like you get him there while you still
have Kamara on the roster for however
long before you know his legal issues
play out but very similarly tool dude
maybe not as impactful as a pure pass
catcher but he can develop in that
regard has all the tools to do so
stick of the division Bryce young
Jonathan Mingo DJ Johnson Carolina
Panthers biggest head scratcher of the
draft so far
I think so this was a it's a weird draft
it kind of felt to me a little desperate
I know there are Mingo fans out there
but 39th overall pick is you know that's
like where Debo Samuel went that's where
Michael Pittman went that's where uh T
Higgins went in that range honestly I
can live with Mingo at
39.80 though that one felt insane that
was the first guy to come off the board
in this draft so he was pick 80 that I
had a udfa grade on and it happens every
year there's one or two but
usually I'll say this so so steals are
not often as good as they sound on paper
but reaches are often as bad as they
sound on paper not a lot of times do
guys reach highly for one that the
consensus the you know the opinion of
most people around the NFL or the guys
doing it in media are saying isn't good
and he has 174th on the pro football
network consensus board and they took
him at 80 overall usually those guys the
track record of those guys just is not
strong over the history of the draft
yeah we've had we were in here on
Thursday night with Micah Parson
obviously plays for the Dallas Cowboys
they get his guy mozzie Smith they also
get Luke's Schoonmaker they also end up
with demarvian overshone what do you
think the Cowboys are going to do today
they've got pick 27 and pick uh pick one
they have once a 129 169 one in the
fourth one in the fifth I think they did
a great job of hitting needs right I
think the Cowboys see where they're at
as a franchise and see where the NFC is
at and say
we can win a Super Bowl or at least get
to a Super Bowl right now we have a
roster capable of doing so so when
that's the case I can kind of back
myself into a corner in certain
positions and I don't even disagree on
the value here but I can say I needed
nose tackle I need a tight end because
those are the two positions that if we
hit on get us the Super Bowl Smith
obviously you saw Michael Parsons on day
one how he felt about that I know I'm
not that excited about it but I am
excited that is a perfect fit for what
they needed on that side of the ball and
then Schoonmaker is the most NFL Ray
tight end you're gonna get that on the
draft Yeah Planet Michigan does a lot
for you in terms of what you're able to
do what they ask you to do and what they
expect you to do so yeah I agree with
you on that
I do think though
still not gonna be enough to put more
pump what the Eagles did in that same
division yeah are you kidding me like
that they had a good draft the Eagles
had a great draft that was
Eagles had it the Eagles had a great
draft I mean let's go ahead and let's go
ahead and take a look at it here we go
we got the Pickers in what we got what
do we got let's see what we got here I
was in Nick's out of area look at that
oh this was one of my top guys available
we're writing down who we're going to
discuss who I want to see some top small
schoolers Old Dominion right tackle I I
think he
can truthfully I think he's like more
NFL ready than the guy they drafted in
the first round last year in Trevor
Penning in terms of pass protection I
thought he had a great week at the
Senior Bowl I think he moves really well
but also a guy who I thought could also
play guard at the next level six six
three eighteen uh just needs to get a
Little Bit Stronger to hold up to NFL
caliber uh sort of strength but that's
that's to be expected you know a lot of
guys coming in the draft with that same
sort of knock and then figure it out
this is a guy who I think is a starting
tackle in the NFL to get a starting
tackle this is why they obviously move
up here to get a starting tackle at this
point in the fourth round I think this
is a is a great pick my opinion we don't
have the grades anymore no but I would
be tapping a plus right now I like him
he's someone and most of the clips that
we saw we got a chance to watch him play
it against ECU that's an FPS school we
got a chance to play hold up against
Virginia Tech that's a power five school
and he he not only held his own he
succeeded they decided we're going to go
away from this guy we've seen him play
left tackle we've seen him play right
tackle he can get those things done I
think at this level at the fourth spot
or in the fourth round top of the fourth
great spot for him and I want to ask you
a question because you got a little bit
of time before the next thing happens
before the uh before the Raiders come up
how do you evaluate small school versus
big school guys when we get into the
back half of the draft yeah it's a it's
a unique sort of weighing that you have
to do because the tape's different right
watching a guy who played four years in
the SEC versus you know where every week
There's an NFL player lined up across
from whereas Nick salivary there wasn't
an NFL player lined up across from him
until he went to the Senior Bowl right
like you get a week of seeing that guy
with an NFL player lined up across from
so that's why you have to go back to
traits you know you have to go back to
physical capabilities uh how the guy
moves how the guy uses hands how he
plays the game of football not
necessarily how well he played the game
football because his tape is level of
dominance that like you're just not
going to see from a lot of SEC tackles
or a lot of Big Ten tackles and that
sort of thing so it's difficult but you
you have to rely on your eyes and eyes
don't lie in terms of like this is what
wins at the NFL level this is what it
should look like at the Collegiate level
so it's once you get to this point in
the draft you're either looking for guys
who played at a super high level at
small schools with the traits that it
takes to win at the NFL level are you
looking for good athletes with what I
like to call good excuses where it's
they maybe have all the physical tools
that it takes but there's something
about them whether it's they have to
change positions whether it's they were
playing out of position whether it's
they had an injury or whether it's the
scheme they were in just doesn't fit
their skill set those are the guys on
target at this point draft here we go
the pick is in and what do we have here
scoring Bennett jacorian I can't see
that far there we go jacorian Bennett
jacorian Bennett the Raiders picked
Jacory Bennett give me a talk about this
guy so Corner out of Maryland he was one
of the fastest Corners I actually think
he was the fastest corner or second
fastest Corner DJ Turner's fast corner
it's got my 4-3 speed it shows on tape
he just is a little tight framed 510 188
you saw him get pushed around a little
bit but guys got real deal make up speed
he has man coverage sort of skill set
here uh obviously the Raiders need all
the help they can get at the cornerback
position but I I don't think his tape
was too far behind his teammates Deontay
Banks Deontay Banks has a much more
projectable physical skill set but this
was a damn good cornerback Duo there at
Maryland this past year not a lot of
teams got the best of these two I love
the way he plays that flat foot tough
technique where he's lined up off six
yards flat foot collision and then carry
he can do that really well he is like
tightly wound though you can tell the
way his upper body is built he's tightly
wound so he's got
um listen jakorian Bennett has got a lot
of skills and again we talked about this
with Illinois we hinted at it with
Maryland with their earlier pick with it
with his teammate there are other people
playing good football there are Ohio
State Penn State and Michigan in the Big
Ten and this is one of them that that
Maryland secondary again for them to
have two guys come off the board that's
going to be in the recruiting material
come to Maryland play play Corner we'll
get it done for you on their snc program
is going to be pumping these guys up
because we talked about Banks as
measurable scoring goes 4-3 40 and a
half inch vertical 11-1 broad jump like
the athletic high-end abilities there
like I said the hips the turn change the
direction ability doesn't quite match
his straight line ability that you see
there does he have to play in the slot I
I don't think so because the speed like
usually when a guy has that speed you
still want him on the outside but I I do
think he is going to struggle against
bigger wide receiversity just based upon
the size I think but the big thing for
me watching again to play that kind of
that tough technique where you are
flat-footed waiting for that guy to
Collision you and he can you mirror him
so you can get hands on and then reroute
and disrupt the timing with the
quarterback it's a really good show for
me so I love that um let's go back to
what we're talking about though that
evaluation process between small school
big school and
what is it do you think that salivary
you think he was dominant at ODU not
like that obviously so in past
protection is it looks different right
when you're dominating the Run game
that's easier to highlight than when
you're dominating pass protection just
because dominance of past protection
looks like playing patty cake you know
20 times a game is what it is you're not
pancaking dudes you're not seeing that
physical ability and you're never going
to see that from salivary he's not a
Trevor penning-like athlete who's going
to physically manhandle you he's going
to win with technique he's going to win
with positioning but that's also how you
win in the NFL right you know physical
dominance is great the the Trent
Williams is of the world like that's how
you reach the Pinnacle but a lot of
starters around the league a lot of
high-end starters you know the Mitchell
Schwartz's of the world we're not oh
yeah Elite athletes right you know he
likes to say you all saw the combine
testing of me because it was objectively
pretty poor but it's still a skill
position even if we don't call it a
skill position often of line needs skill
development as much if not more than a
lot of other positions on the football
field oh yeah so we got folks in the
chat right now they're saying Eagles or
Eagles are overrated okay yeah they were
weren't they just in the Super Bowl
so I think that's really tough thing to
say uh we got to pick in and then we're
going to get back to the Eagles
um there you go oh my Lord George and
Nora Ringo
here we go I I don't even I didn't even
love Keely Ringo as a prospect like when
he was getting first round hype I was
like you know I don't see it he's too uh
he's too big honestly like he does not
change directions well because he's like
210 pounds he moves kind of just a
little he doesn't have the twitch that
you want from a lockdown outside corner
but at 210 pounds he plays the position
differently he can get up at the line of
scrimmage and end reps before they start
because he is that size and then if you
do get a step on them
he's one of the fast corners of the
draft goes four three five and was
actually like timed faster in high
school so this is a guy who has Real
Deal makeup speed plays with his hair on
fire you're never gonna question his
effort on the back end and man he's only
20 years old this guy will not turn 21
until this summer like there is a lot of
Developmental potential here that we
have not seen
Eagles to get them again it's just like
it doesn't have to be that hard it
doesn't have to be that hard yeah some
of these teams are making it look hard
but like just grab the dudes who are
falling for
unbeknownst reasons and you're gonna
look like a good football team this is a
great pick yeah I I love Ringo I I've
loved him for I've loved him since the
day I saw him like this is a guy that I
have a first sight yeah it truly was
he's super I love how physical he is
right and he loves he gets hands on you
he's one of the few Corners in this
draft that gets Hands-On guys but very
consistently most guys they open the
they open the gate right what I mean is
they open their hips and they try they
try to start running because they're
scared of getting beat with the speed
that he has with his with his ability
he's not worried about getting beat deep
what he wants to do is as you mentioned
he wants to kill the route before it
happens and if he can do that that means
that the quarterback loses their read
immediately look at the way he triggers
here on the Run boom let's go make a
play like he's he's a good he's a good
run Defender I think he for me he was
still one of the best all-around corners
Zone Man versus The Run do you think he
has a switch to safety do you think he
could stick in it corner just a
positional corner where do you think he
fits I think he's keeping that corner
he's just kind of like a silo corner
where you're not going to be super
versatile with them you're not kicking
them inside you're not asking them to
really Mirror full route trees that sort
of thing but if you're backing off into
cover three cover four right he's he can
play that he can play that and again
like I said we're talking about some
Corners going before this that are 23
years old that are getting up their
fifth year guys yeah this is a 20 year
old a redshirt sophomore coming out at
this point in the draft who's been
productive already
um I love the pick tackle Blake Freeland
there we go thank you Connor Hughes he's
back on it today oh congress locked in
freeland's interesting he was a guy I I
uh thought was one of the best
developmental tackles in this draft
class because I mean he is a special
athlete he comes from a family full of
athletes he broke the combine record uh
for vertical jump I believe with a 37
inch vertical at over 300 pounds which
is just freaky stuff and you see in the
Run game 37 inch vertical and 10 foot
broad jump you see it in the running
game with him whether it's a lot of
stretch Zone at BYU his get off the line
of scrim is just Elite I mean he gets on
guys quickly
balance concerns you see him play a
little top heavy there gets out over his
toes too often in my for my uh liking
but also he's at six foot eight 300
pounds is skinny he needs to put on 15
to 20 pounds of muscle before this guy's
seen the football field but he's going
to a spot where you know they have a
left tackle and Bernard Raymond that
they drafted last year that they like
they have a right tackle and Braden
Smith that they like a lot obviously
this is a developmental dude at a place
where you can have them afford him the
time to develop so uh I I think this is
a pick that I I like I think a swing
tackle potential and it's definitely not
a guy though that you're moving inside
there to play Right Guard at six foot
eight there's no way he's gonna play
guard he's definitely going to be a
tackle they just picked up Anthony
Richardson so they need as much
offensive lineup as they can get
obviously he's a developmental player
but getting him helps you keep again as
you said last night you don't need an
offensive lineman until you need one
yeah so you got to draft them before you
need them and that's what they're what
they're doing with this right here we
have the I believe it's the Patriots
that are coming up next on the clock but
let's go back to this Eagles talk
because I wanted to hit on this the
Eagles we saw the Eagles pick up Jalen
Carter at nine Nolan Smith at 30. both
in the first round
Tyler Steen at at in the in the third
round yep third round Sydney Brown
fourth round Keeley Ringo
I mean they probably have from the 2021
Georgia team now which was the gold
standard for modern college football
defenses yes from the 2020 not this past
Year's team but two years ago yes they
have the five most impactful players for
my money Jordan Davis
Jalen Carter Nolan Smith and the Kobe
Dean Keely Ringo those were the five
best players on that George yeah I agree
those were the guys that I mean now
there were other good guys don't get me
wrong I mean like Clay Walker was sick
yeah Nintendo very good yes but those
were the those were the five guys that
was it that was the those what is what
key did to make it the best defense ever
they are all now Philadelphia Eagles for
the next four three to four years at
least that's Insanity Insanity yeah what
do you think what do you think the Pats
are gonna do here with this pick uh gosh
I mean the Pats have had a good draft
right yeah I'm a fan of what they've
done I love Marte mapu I love the way he
plays the game Christian Gonzalez was
one of if not the biggest deal of the
first round
past few things their own way I'm trying
to for trying to predict I wouldn't be
surprised fourth round I guess they won
quarterback last year but like they've
got the corners wide receivers
they haven't addressed the wide receiver
situation yet I would love for them Nick
herbig the Wisconsin linebackers okay
they love their undersized kind of edge
hybrids that can drop into coverage the
true 3-4 outside linebacker types they
have a Josh Uche there who is one of the
best and that molds
Nick herbig's just just caught probably
like a little less athletic version of
Joshua yeah but he's super productive
but yes that's the thing that's the
thing with Nick Herbert is he's
incredibly productive for that and
listen I love all those Wisconsin guys
they all play with their hair on fire
what do we got let's see
oh Jake Andrews Jake Andrews I felt like
dude that felt like a patriot when I was
sitting the uh Troy interior offensive
line
um he felt like a patriot watching him
on tape I mean the guys got the gosh who
was the old Patriots center that was
there for David Andrews that it feels a
lot like David Andrews I don't know if
their brothers actually now and I'm
thinking about this but there is high
effort plays the game the right way
a little physically overmatched when I
saw him at the Senior Bowl but a guy
with developmental potential because
he's going to work his butt off to do so
so that's a patriot type of interior
offensive line no relation okay no
relationship we've got no relationship
okay who do we have coming up next right
now we are on the we are currently
waiting for the sixth pick of the third
round of the or the fifth fourth round
of the draft goodness gracious the
Seahawks are on the clock the Seahawks
let's take a look at their what they've
done so far
the Seahawks are a team they're one of
those teams that have multiple picks
a team that was able to they needed
defensive line wide receiver offensive
line they're able to go out there and
they get
Devon Witherspoon we love him Jackson
Smith and jigba love him that's both
first round guys second round Derek Hall
Zach Chardonnay so they've addressed the
wide receiver they were just Edge
they've hit on running back which wasn't
necessarily A need but it's a thing they
wanted and they address defensive line
so right here what would you what do you
want them to do with what they what
they've got going on because they've
already hit on a wide receiver they've
already got an edge rusher
is there somebody in the longest
defensive interior that would be
interesting for them well I mean out of
bar a yeah he's still up there still up
there that that'd be a guy that I'd be
intrigued by if I'm a Seahawks fan but
I'll say this John Schneider had one of
the best no he had the best s draft run
from I believe it was 2010 to 2012 of
any GM probably ever he drafted multiple
future Hall of Famers in that space
last year I had a lot of bad drafts they
traded away a bunch of first round picks
that's kind of how they got to that
point where they trade Russell Wilson
last year he was back one of the best
drafts of anyone the attic Kenneth
Walker Charles cross Abraham Lucas
treekwon and now this year poised to do
a lot of the same at Anthony Bradford
here there we go into your offensive
lineman one of the most powerful guards
in this draft class it shows immediately
on tape with this guy I mean he is built
like a brick house
you see it right there from his lower
body to his upper body the man can move
the line of scrimmage not too dissimilar
to obviously former LSU interior
offensive lineman that's there right now
uh in Gabe uh no not Gabe Jackson he was
the one who's left uh who's there left
guard let me pull it up right here look
at that the power of computers blanking
on Damien Lewis that's who
not too dissimilar in terms of Bill wise
now Damian Lewis was a little more
accomplished than past protection coming
out that's probably my concerns with
Bradford but the traits are there long
arms big base can play low just the guy
who needs some seasoning at this point
in the draft uh with what they want to
do now running the football obviously
yeah this is a guy that can move in the
line scrimmage give space to attack
Chardonnay yeah so they address they get
her they get a running back they get
another they get an offensive lineman
you get a wide receiver you get Edge
you're doing they're doing what they
need to do oh by the way they got what
many consider to be the best corner in
the jail so good giraffe for the
Seahawks especially as one of those
teams that have multiple picks Nick
who's next up dude well we got to pick
who's in there oh they're coming hot now
Dylan Horton TCU Edge Texans
they're they're going some homegrown
guys right they went Houston wide
receiver tank Dell yeah they're going
now TCU they're they're they're going
span the state of Texas uh he's a guy
who
High effort High motor doesn't quite
know what he's doing now and just kind
of a limited limited athlete like he's
not a special athlete the guy we saw
that run in the third round where it was
just like DJ Johnson
um Byron young guys who were just like
freaks Yep this is he's a tier below
that those guys athletically but he get
he wants to get after it you'll see him
track down a lot of quarterbacks outside
the pocket a lot of his production comes
on plays like that where it's just pure
effort uh obviously one of the keys to
this TCU defense from a season to go but
you're gonna have to coach this guy up
as a pastor so he needs to add some
moves to his Arsenal but Seahawks
Seahawks need depth though you know they
just need some people there as you're
seeing here a lot of these that's just
that's just effort again that's just him
not giving up on football plays that's
what you consistently saw out of himante
yeah so
we got Jake Andrews to the Pats we've
got what Jalen Horton to the Seahawks
we're waiting on the Houston Texans now
uh let me ask you something about TCU
because we saw Kim J Miller come off the
board
um what do we think about
D Winters okay he's to me I had a udfa
grade on Wednesday I I did not see him
as the draft for Prospect the one guy
from TCU defense that I thought
is wet and I want to see come off the
board here's Trey Tomlinson the Dan
Thomas's nephew yeah the five foot eight
Corner who's going to be one of the
smallest Corners ever drafted oh here we
go
we got it we got a top 50 player come
off the board here there he is edible
way
the Colts making some plays right now
Northwestern right yes the Northwestern
DN slash DT comes off the board he is
the freakiest athlete along the
defensive line
I've ever seen he ran a four four nine
forty at 282 pounds
he is a 109 pounds heavier than Jordan
Addison around the exact same 40 times
Jordan Addison plays wide receiver this
guy plays defensive line and so he was a
little out of position in my opinion at
Northwestern playing a lot more on the
edge now they kicked him on the interior
a little this year but he did not look
comfortable because he really hadn't
played there right I thought he went
down in the Senior Bowl and he looked
like he belonged he had a bull rush rep
against Jared Patterson Northwestern
guard slash or excuse me Notre Dame
guard Center where he walked him back to
the goal posts from the goal line on a
bull rush Patterson was pissed
afterwards but that just shows you the
level of explosiveness this guy
possesses and yeah he's undersized for
interior guy but he has a six foot ten
inch wingspan he has long arms this is a
pick that I am floored he lasted this
long there has to be some injury or some
reason why because he is a much better
Prospect in terms of potential than the
that group of guys we just saw come up
the board in the third round they were
high-end athletes this is a higher end
athlete right with more project NFL
tools I am and with better tape frankly
in my opinion Florida lasted this long
but the Colts start off with two Elite
athletes at two positions that are
valuable that I think could see the
field at some point during the rookie
contract so the fan of what the Colts
have done here on day three
it's just a Colts hang on a second
my order is looking different I'm
looking at them so the trades are coming
so hot right now yeah we've got so we
got Dylan Horton already we're okay
we're just ahead that's the thing that's
what threw me off boom there we go so
we're looking at the on the the Colts we
already know their pick we already know
who they got
that's amazing this is this is a good
pick you think you think how do you
think you think the Colts use him on the
edge or do you are they kicking him down
inside and asking him to bulk up a
little bit I think they're kicking him
to three Tech like in that defense you
obviously have DeForest Buckner but he's
getting a little up there yes he is in
age and you've seen his production maybe
take a step back from when he was at his
prime after they first traded for him in
recent years and they just like athletes
there right that's Chris Ballard's Mo he
drafted quittypay who was a freak uh he
is consistently done so over the years
and this is a guy who's not tooled too
dissimilarly like you watch their tape
and it doesn't look too dissimilar from
a guy like quittipay and what he did at
Michigan so man at this point the draft
the picks the two picks they've had in
the fourth round right now I'm a big big
fan of so yeah so guys folks we are the
reason I got that messed up is we are
ahead of the draft and to reference it
the coach got Blake Freeland and then
they added in um
by worry it's it's like a uh it's like a
Canadian Guy saying he's at a bar yeah
at a bar eh at a bar eh got it um oh
that was that's the perfect explanation
gold draft though yeah Anthony
Richardson Julie's Prince Josh Downs
they've had they've had themselves a
draft guys I've had a draft here we go
DeJuan Jones from Ohio State he is the
pick for the Browns this is a guy we
thought could go a lot earlier than this
we're wait he had to wait until day
three to hear his name called he's a
massive giant human Man compared him to
Orlando Brown just because he's so huge
Orlando Brown the kid at the cat out of
Oklahoma he's humongous this is a huge
player like three six eight three
seventy four guess what could be bigger
oh dude yeah I mean 374 is when he had
to cut down to make the combine and run
a five three five forty there on tape
he's probably pushing 400 right and he
can play at that size though yeah I mean
I usually do not like bigger slower
tackles but I am a fan of DeJuan Jones
for the same reason I was a fan of
Orlando Brown coming out the guy gets
the position and he's also like so
freakishly big that he can play the game
differently than your run-of-the-mill
six foot four 315 pound tackle right
because at six eight 374 with 11 and 5 8
inch hands the biggest hands ever
measured at the combine
36 and 3 8 inch arms the biggest arms
longest arms of anyone in this draft
class he gets on you he short sets a lot
he you go quick sets guys a lot where he
just gets his hands on him and then once
he does it's over you cannot get off him
and around him with those hands with
that length now he does need to be
protected a little bit if you are a team
that's a heavy drop back deep drop
passing game put my tackles on an island
this isn't going to be your guy right
like he can be susceptible to Inside
Moves he can get knocked off balance
when he faces speed
but if you put a tight end to his side
if you have a mobile quarterback like
obviously the Cleveland Browns do that
you want to keep in the pocket that has
to be kind of bull rushed you're not
bull rushing this dude you're just quite
frankly not going to and he obviously
goes to a great situation to develop but
my favorite story about DeJuan Jones was
he tweaked he tweaked like a minor
injury after day one of the Senior Bowl
was sitting out but he still comes to
practice he's watching the one-on-ones
and he's calling out the moves that the
Defenders are going to do before they do
them because he has watched these guys
his tape studies to that point and he
just knows and he's like watch the
inside move watch the bull rush get your
hands up he's no that to me is skill
that to me is what the high-end tackles
at the next level half that's why I go
to bat for this guy and why at this
point in the draft that's a steal for
the brown yeah I mean that's an A plus
if we're still doing great yeah but the
thing here's the thing I love that works
on me for two that story works on me two
ways one that means he studies yes love
a guy that studies two
he don't know those guys from Adam those
other offensive lineman but he's helping
out his group yep so when he gets into
that offensive line room with the Browns
he's going to help make everybody better
I think that goes a long way that's
something that you get I think he got
that from Ohio State playing with a guy
like Paris Johnson it's one of those
things where you end up working together
because you know that if you guys are
all pulling in the same direction
there's nobody that can beat you yes
except George the Browns now so they
went Cedric Tillman in the third syaki
Ika in the third as well and now DeJuan
Jones they got three guys who I had
higher on my board than where they came
off the board and at three positions
that are valuable positions and
positions that can make an impact on
this roster all right folks we got a
trade you see right there on the board
the Jets trade with the Pats with pats
so they're coming up to 112 for 120 and
184. so here we go the Patriots they
select
they moved up to get him Chad
they moved up to get him so I'm going to
ask you to run on kickers is real here
here we go let me ask you one of these
questions that I put together
um yeah can we talk because right now
this is a great good time to talk about
value versus fit yeah maybe they need to
come out there maybe they need a kicker
but it's not good value right yeah like
what's the difference like that if you
need a kicker sure but you don't have to
value a kicker so much to give away
those two picks yeah so I mean you think
back to whether it's Alberto Aguayo
whether it was a second rounder whether
it's uh Sebastian Janikowski yeah who is
the the Browns guy they drafted Oh My
Goodness but I think about might was it
Mike Nugent too yeah just kicking is a
small sample size yes you do not get too
many attempts and especially at the
points that are valuable when you get to
the NFL which is 45 plus and so you're
only evaluating a guy on uh you need a
lot of attempts to basically get a big
enough sample size to feel confident
that whatever percentage she was kicking
at in college is the percentage she's
going to kick at in the NFL yes and so
the draft track record there is a zero
percent correlation between draft
position at the kicker position and how
good you are in the NFL right so you
need a kicker but a lot of times
um there's just so many factors that go
into success at the NFL level that when
you draft one you just really don't know
what you're getting unfortunately so so
the value versus uh versus fit though
it's
it's a difficult conversation and it's
something that we saw the Lions
basically say like we we just we we
prioritize we prioritize fit prioritize
fit and there's multiple ways to build a
roster but I think the more you just
focus on value and the more you say you
know admit that I don't necessarily know
what's best like I don't know better at
any position than anyone else as long as
I and you've seen this with the Eagles
and what they do as long as I prioritize
the positions that are consistently
valuable that provide the biggest cap
Edge for me in that if I draft a
defensive end and he plays well I don't
have to go out and pay 20 million
dollars in free agency Forum whereas
running back if I draft a running back
and plays well well I could have gone
out and spent eight million dollars on
Zeke you know like eight million dollars
on a quality NFL running back and
knowing I'm gonna get a good one that to
me is the biggest difference and why I
say you know try to prioritize value as
much as possible in the draft yeah it's
it's they're still operating in a very
small economy
itself but also each team the Falcons
have selected DB Clark Phillips Phillips
out of Utah this was a guy I I find him
to be phenomenal I think he's got great
patient feet he put he goes up and makes
plays he plays bigger than he is and
he's got kind of that what is it was it
nominee Aston watt Tire Style game where
he will not hear about him all game
and you do not challenge this man
the only the only the reason why false
here yeah five night is you literally
can see it on screen five nine one eight
four four five one Bingo small and on
athletic is a bad combo for a lot of
positions specifically Corner
specifically corner but I'll say this
he's not playing outside corner that's
where he played at Utah this is a slot
Corner going to a team that needs a slot
corner you have your outside dudes you
have AJ Terrell you got Jeffrey acuda
those are press long outside corners the
comp right there Mike Hilton this is a
this is a man slot corner like him and
man coverage is when I thought he was at
his best getting his eyes on receivers
from off position and being able to
match and mirror I thought he was
special in that regard yeah he just now
the problem is tracking speed down the
football field but if you throw them in
the slot track speed on the football
field don't matter you ain't running a
ton of verticals from the slot you have
a safety over the top that's how that
position works so guys a dog guy gets
after he plays the game the right way
this is a fantastic pick in my opinion
for the Atlanta Falcons I love that last
clip that we just showed where he was
playing off and then you watch him do
that flat foot read and then push the
wide receiver out just a little bit
enough for him to kind of touch cloth
slow him down bring him down to your
speed bring that if that's a 4-4 guy
that's a 4-3 guy Collision him bring him
down to your speed now you can run with
him and that's the beauty of playing
corner there are all these little things
that you have to do to make sure that
you can run with them bring them down to
your speed and go make plays love this
pick I'm a big Clark Phillips fan we got
a division of rivalry divisional rival
here with the Carolina Panthers on the
clock let's see what they do and I think
their pick is in and then we're gonna
we're gonna head into the Bears are
coming up next
Panthers are really that oh here we go
they redeemed themselves I love Chandler
Zavala let's go we got we got footage
for him let's show her he's a NC State
interior offensive lineman played guard
so he transfers from D2 two years at D2
transfers NC State first year I think
only four games then had a back injury
and then this past year like wasn't on
Radars because of that like no one knew
about this guy from a scouting
perspective heading into this season
balls out this past season that has a
tremendous year I think he allowed only
four pressures all season long at guard
and then he goes to his pro day and had
the best pro day in my opinion of any of
the Interior offensive linemen in this
draft class uh it is six foot four 316
pounds and he had a 32 inch vertical a
7583 cone a four seven short shuttle and
did 30 bench press reps the guy can move
the guy uses his hands well it's either
the confirms TJ Lang I'm a big fan of
this guy he was my third ranked guard in
this draft class and not too far behind
guys like Osiris Torrance and
Stephenville who are my one and two like
he was close to them on tape in my
opinion so to get him at this point I
think he could steal a starting gig away
maybe not day one but at some point from
the guards they have there in Carolina
let me ask you something
the Panthers go out and get they they're
going to get Icky iguana from NC State
now they add Zavala in from NC State
they found a well that they like yeah
but I mean they play next to each other
last year you got Brady Christensen at
guard right now he to me he was always a
tackle I don't think guards his best fit
I would almost want to just put him back
as my swing tackle behind Taylor Mouton
behind iki aquanu one of them gets hurt
like entries do happen right in every
year you got a guy can slide right in
and now Chandler Zavala plays that left
guard next to his college teammate when
they were such a dominant Run game a
couple years ago uh this this Panthers
line I will say this I I don't trust the
Panthers weapons right now right I think
they still need to do a lot of work in
that regard in the future for Bryce
young but they gave him a good offensive
line This is a line that he can work
with right out the gate that is not
going to be a liability whatsoever I'm
not gonna wait for that but I do think
this is a solid at least average if not
above average offensive line at this
point yeah I think so too and I think
the big key because remember we've all
we've everyone talked about it Bryce
young needs to be protected he's so
small he's so small injury injury and
they're they're working on protecting
him I think that's great he talked about
the weapons there the character they
just drafted Jonathan Mingo they have DJ
Chark laviska Chenault who we mentioned
yesterday hasn't really kind of lived up
to what we expected Terrace Marshall Jr
same thing so this is going to be
interesting to see if they get anything
else oh by the way they did also get
outside Adam thielen so that's a that's
an upgrade for them I'm looking at their
receiving core though and I'm thinking
it's third down I'm seeing pressed man
across the board who am I throwing it to
exactly and I don't there's not one I
love just yet so I do think they're
still in need of a number one this could
be a team that DeAndre Hopkins would
make a lot of sense for you know if
DeAndre Hopkins is available this is a
team I would be kicking the tires on
just because that's what I'm missing uh
so far Bears pick is in they pick
Rashawn Johnson the backup running back
from Texas what do you think about him
I'm a fan of his now he is the David
Montgomery replacement in this office
they are similar-ish players in that not
super great long speed but great between
the tackles running backs great short
yardage running backs and tremendous
contact bounce he actually had a higher
broken tackle rate than Bijan Robinson
now a lot of times that's because he's
the guy playing mop up Duty he's the guy
playing against the smaller schools when
it's out of touch but at the same time
the guy is elusive he's he came to Texas
as a quarterback was supposed to be the
backup and before his freshman year they
had injuries at running back and they
said you want to switch the running back
he said yeah and he said let's go and
now he was backing up Bijon the past few
years but he was doing his thing when he
was called upon like I mentioned that
high broken tackle rate uh just
doesn't have like I said the long speed
once he gets out into space he can get
hawked down he went four five eight at
the combine so you have that aspect
that's going to be missing from his game
but he's got long arms he's got a good
stiff arm and he is a powerful back that
will not go down on First Contact so
basically like I said just Dave
Montgomery walks in free agency this guy
slots right in no down don't drop off
and play they have Deontay Foreman
Khalil Herbert they've got left Travis
Homer Tristan Ebner where does he where
does he fit in with those four so I love
Khalil Herbert as a starter there I I
think he has the best speed of those
guys and I want speed with Justin Fields
right now truthfully like I'm surprised
I would have I hope they still go for
like a Keaton Mitchell later on like
someone who can really hit home runs but
I like little Herbert as a starter but I
think you're going to get a uh by
committee backfield there and it's going
to be a pretty good split between him
and Roshan Johnson I think both those
guys get a lot of touches there we go I
like that all right we got um
let's see what they got
don't screw it up
oh he's not he's not bad okay okay there
we go the Packers have selected Colby
wooden tell us about him so Kobe wooden
is 6'4 273 he's a tweener so 273 you're
thinking I mean they just drafted a guy
who's 272 in the first round and you're
thinking Edge right but this is an
interior defensive lineman I think he's
very skilled I think he knows what he's
doing but he's not a super high-end
athlete you know I just said the guy
drafted the first round went four five
eight in the 40. he went four seven nine
at the same size so so not quite the
explosiveness but he's a little quick
uses his hands really well on the
interior and the guy that if you know
you can continue to put on muscle get
into the 290 range that's a player
that's a guy that can hold up as a 4-5
technique in that defense so at this
point in the draft they're just trying
to get depth trying to get guys who when
they're on the football field aren't
liabilities right because they had too
many of those a season to go after some
injuries struck along their defensive
line is a guy that won't be a liability
I really like his ability to disengage
like that's something I really like
about him like you see him right there
with the throw that guy almost felt if
that if that guard didn't run into his
own player he would have been on his
back I love his ability to throw he
disengages incredibly violently and
that's what I like to see out of the
player in that position even though he's
not as big as what you would expect from
a three technique or as big as you would
expect from a guy that's playing at the
one the reality of it is with the
violence with the strength with that
power comes the ability to disengage and
we just watched those clips and we got a
chance to watch this guy truly disengage
and that's a huge pick for them so I
think he's a guy that's going to be able
to contribute pretty quickly yeah I
think he's a rotational player but you
needed rotational players you lost
um gosh I'm blanking on the guy's name
they lost the Vikings in free agency but
like you lost some pieces to this
defensive line it was already thin so it
definitely
a Val a position of need for them even
though the value that's kind of where I
had him on the board in the 120 range
right you know he's one he goes at 116
that's pretty spot on this is going to
be really interesting to see how this
all shakes out because we just saw we
just saw guys like Dylan Horton come off
the board we saw Roshan Johnson come off
the board we've got another one coming
off the board right here let's see
City Style there we go go look at that
drafting athletes along the interior
offensive line
so let me see what happened here so the
the Patriots traded up to get a kicker
and now they are getting
offensive lineman this I'm a fan of this
guy I had him 1 14th on my draft board
so this is you know comes off the board
117 so a little before Ethan where he
came off the board but he's six foot
five 320 and if you watch here the guy
can move you know he can move a lot
better than someone like an Anthony
Bradford who just came off the board
from LSU this is not a phone booth guard
this is a guard that can climb to the
second level locate guys he ran a 5.07
40 at the combine at that size
um obviously at Eastern Michigan level
of competition is a concern I do think
he's not a day one Starter by any means
despite you know having six years of
Collegiate play being 24 years old
already he's probably still your backup
guard but
you have two good guards in place there
in New England you don't need a starter
you need depth and this is a great depth
piece for them in that you know if
called upon I think he can step in and
start two for you so uh the Patriots no
interior line scouting I would not
question them too much on that that's
what I was gonna I was gonna it really
feels like the Patriots are kind of
gearing up for another like Belichick
kind of be like okay let me show you
what I can do this is how you are let me
show you where I'm the man they're
setting up for the zag which is the
ground and pound they are trying to get
back to what the Steelers are kind of
trying to get back to which is just move
the football take teams out of these two
high shells that everyone wants to play
so let's talk let's before we get to the
next pick let's talk about that because
we're a little bit in front and the
commanders are on the clock
when you say the zig you set up for the
zag so basically we're seeing smaller
smaller linebackers we're seeing more
five defensive back packages more six
defensive back packages yes but we've
talked about Steelers so I'll go with
the Pats they are beefing it up so that
your guys won't be able to stop there
guys because they got a lot of big dudes
is that is that an accurate
representation I think that's fair like
the rise of teams like you mentioned
playing either 220 pound backers that
don't want to take on blocks to save
their life that are taking safeties out
of the box making them play the run with
six guys seven guys at times
um
when that's the case you better make
them pay when they want to do that you
have to be able to or else teams are
going to live in that and when you live
in these two high shells it just puts
caps on your passing game it makes your
quarterback have to be damn near Perfect
Right In The Underneath an intermediate
game to move the ball down the football
field because one drop one air and pass
and the other three and out you're
you're coming out so getting that five
six yards on first down when you do see
a light box with the Run game is
invaluable in today's NFL
oh pick system Braden Daniels
um that's what the Washington commanders
select Braden Daniel so
this is a High high-end athlete you
watch a move that looks like a tight end
but he is kind of built like a tight end
too 294 pounds he came in at the combine
playing tackle there started his career
guard he will be a guard at the next
level at 294. I think he's going to be a
guard or a center truthfully at that
size as well probably he's at his best
because this dude pops off the line of
scrimmage his twitch is evident from
snap one to the last snap of the game he
will fly but he is
the guy is out of control I mean he he
plays the game the cop there is Kendra
Green who's really struggled to
transition the NFL because of similar
reasons in that he flies head down into
contact thinking there's no way in the
world I'm gonna miss this guy and then
more often than not he gets slammed ends
up on his face like there is a lot of
seasoning that he needs but
you give him that seasoning he reminds
me a little bit of like Shaq Mason in
that regard remember Shaq mace coming
out Georgia Tech we're just like look at
that guy fly around the football field
but can he control it control it you get
this guy to control like Shaq Mason uh
finally figured out in New England
before obviously bouncing around after
that you have a starting center slash
guard in the end the cool thing for me
was watching him play against Florida
and Ohio State
two teams that we both have extremely
high Talent levels two teams and we're
gonna see you here again watch the
weight listen get off me okay and then
he wants to go he wants to go run he's
ready to look for somebody else he can
get the job done I love this here boom
okay look at the way he moves to that
second level that's against Penn State
another team that's got a pretty high
Talent level he can do that and that's
what you want you want that in you
mentioned him playing guard I think that
obviously there's got to be some work in
in pass Pro either at either tackle or
guard he's got to be some work in pass
bro but listen when you get a guy like
this you got to be absolutely thrilled
with Braden Daniels because he's so oh
we gotta trade
Kansas City moving up to 119. okay so
Kansas City is now on the clock not the
Vikings okay interesting Kansas City
let's see what they've done so far I
feel like no one's picked in their
actual spot so far in the fourth round
we have of the players
there's been only
five or six players drafted in this
round that were the initial picks by
them good grief
that's incredible
um there we go top players available
hopefully we see Tanner McKinney come
off the board here sometime in the
fourth round I don't think he last past
the fifth he's what's a good fit for
Tanner McKee because I know some folks
haven't don't know who he is didn't
watch a ton of him what's a good fit for
Tanner McKee
good question I I think he's a guy who
is a pocket passer so someone that's
going to uh to me not too dissimilar I
see as a prospect to a guy like
um Brock Purdy who came out last year
and obviously balled out I'm not saying
he's gonna do that by any means but
that's the kind of offense you wanted to
go to is what I'm saying is he can work
the middle of the field really well he's
tall he's the tallest quarterback in
this year six foot six 230 can really
see that area of the field because of it
oh the Chiefs go a little off the wall
here Shamari Connor guy did not have my
top 200 safety out of Virginia Tech
um oh
it's a I'll tell you before we get to
heaven just Virginia Tech wise rough
rough road for them yeah it's been a
like this is a school that there was a
time that they were being called DBU
like they were in the discussion with
LSU with Florida with Florida state with
Miami with Ohio State
and with Texas and now they've kind of
just fallen off the radar okay let's get
to let's get to Shamari Connor uh safety
that yeah you said you didn't have them
in the top 200. did not have them in the
top 200. I think he's just a solid like
I didn't have a top 200 because I think
he's just limited upside wise I think
this is probably more of a special teams
type of pick sure I think he plays the
game in a way that you want a safety
play like he has this sort of aggression
aggression the want to like sticks his
nose in it that sort of football player
that you're getting I just didn't see
high-end coverage ability necessarily on
tape I I don't think he's youth surfing
Brian Cook in that defense by any means
but he's the guy that he you could
probably be reliable at this point in
the draft and again special teams value
as well well we gotta we got a little
quick thing I wanted to ask you about
this when do you start drafting for
special teams specifically so
any time on day three truthfully if
you're an NFL team that is depending on
how bad your special teams are but like
the sixth seventh round is almost
exclusively yeah four special teams if a
guy can't play teams at that point in
the draft
um chances are you're you're not drafted
there's very few teams that take a
chance there
um fourth round at this point is
probably early for me sure but if you
get towards the back end of the fourth
round or if you're a team like the
Chiefs where it's like luxury pick where
do I have a starting spot where is the
guy even going to be able to do anything
for me
on this roster that's when
that's when you can make a play like
this where it's like yeah he's probably
more geared towards special teams but if
you want to put him in the defensive
backfield yeah defensive backfield you
could do it in a pinch yeah I think
that's the key and also it's going to be
interesting to me because
I believe they still have Devin Bush
right and he was a guy that kind of fit
into that same mold of a special teams
guy when he back when he played for the
Bears and when he played and then he got
yes yeah similar it's a similar player
does that mean that they're going to
move on from him I don't know they got I
mean they got Mike Edwards too yeah
Justin Reed they have options at safety
so this is truly just a depth piece yeah
all right what do we got we got the Jets
with the pick in okay Jets what are you
doing
Carter Warren here we go okay Pittsburgh
OT he's I thought he was going to go
higher wow he had an injury this past
season uh I believe he only played two
games before that injury
um and so it comes out actually before
games before that injury misses the
final nine with the knee but he has the
tools kind of I saw him and Wanya Morris
who came off the board around a similar
light I thought whiny is a little more
powerful but these are guys who have the
size six five through eleven have the
length and kind of are close in pass
protection you see it at times with him
in past protection the consistency is
the biggest thing though with him that
we haven't yet seen and then obviously
didn't get to see because he got hurt
this past year cop for him I had was
Yanni Ka juice too it's kind of a
similar guy who came out with injuries
never put it never put together and
obviously it isn't starting anywhere now
but this is this is where you take that
guy to where he figures it out we've
been begging for a right tackle you know
we need that desperate here in New York
this just gives us another swing at that
position another chance that we find our
starting tackle the future so we're
looking at Will McDonald IV
Joe titman
and now Carter Ward for the three picks
that the Jets have had so far they are
clearly looking to shore up that
offensive line
and I think they've they've attacked it
enough two guys that you feel pretty
solid about yeah so I think the first
round they I think they just loved Will
McDonald right that to me was just
Robert Sala saying I like this putting
his nuts out there and saying hi this is
the tape was good enough that I think
he's right here yeah you know right it
wasn't a need wasn't anything like that
but then after that they kind of
scrambled and they're like I wouldn't
even call it scramble Tim was like you
know the first center to come off the
board but basically saying well now we
got to plug the holes that are kind of
missing that we're worried about because
we're in a championship window we trade
for in Rogers for one year not because
we want to just make the playoffs right
we're doing it because we want to win a
Super Bowl so we need guys that can make
an impact tomorrow
Warren I don't think makes an impact
tomorrow but I do think Joe titman
absolutely can I think that's going to
be exciting to see him slide in there
and really kind of be
at some point he's going to run that
offensive line that's the ultimate goal
for him he ain't quite Nick mangled but
this is your
10-year Center type guy there you go
um let me see what else we got here
so well we talked about this because we
got Tippmann going what did he go around
to and then we've got Carter going
around four what other kind of
diminishing odds of
getting on the roster having an impact
on the roster one round one that's a
hundred percent if you're playing you're
you're playing better Point yeah but as
we go down what are we looking at so so
I like to think about it like this round
one is you're starting them whether you
like it or not usually yeah he's going
to be on your team you're you better
have found a guy who is quality starter
now the hit rate's usually more like 50
or lower right truthfully of guys that
are quality Stars that's why I say when
you can find you know a layup like a
Michael Mayer that that is those are
guys that he will be one of the best 30
players in the draft class right like
maybe he falls outside the top 30 but he
will be eventually
um so I still advocate for those guys
but it's that's what you're looking for
in round one two and three
is kind of where GMS separate themselves
round one picks oftentimes pick
themselves rounds two and three is when
you cannot find does you cannot find
guys that cannot see the football field
you have to have at least guys who when
they are uh on a football field or at
least not liabilities in rounds two and
three right that to me is where that
point in the draft and then four five
six seven is icing on the cake right if
you find something there great more
likely than not that's a guy who's going
to be a backup for you that you're
hoping you don't have to go to free
agency to go sign right because of the
rookie wage deal those guys are super
cheap at that point in the draft they
are the cheapest players that you will
ever get on your football field are
fourth round picks and later in udfas
that's as little as you'll pay a guy and
so if you can get a guy that say you
know my corner goes down I have to sub
them in or my offensive line my Center
goes down and brain Daniels has to come
in there for me if he cannot be a
problem for you that's a win like that
that we call that a win for a fourth
round pick if that guy is not a problem
when he sees the football field so uh
again
the expectations for these guys is
backups at this point but you
you're not you're not you're not
necessarily swinging for the fences you
know like we said in round three you're
swinging for competency right here is
all you're really looking for we're
looking at your big board right here
Tanner McKee's at the top are you so
surprised that Luke whippler's still
there I am very surprised about Luke
whippler some of these other guys I get
why herbig's a tweener Travis Hodge
Tomlinson super undersized Antonio
Johnson just a slot over the course of
his career but whippler's like a
redshirt sophomore coming out of Center
he is a young Center yeah super
productive very good really like
only struggled only bad tape this past
season was against mozzie Smith and
that's a first rounder who's a grown man
in terms of his play strength and yeah
that's why you're worried is because
whippler's not that strong but again
he's a redshirt sophomore he is three
years younger than John Michael Schmitz
who came out and went in the second
round right and I thought their tape was
somewhat comparable from this past
season so you're telling me in three
years this guy's not going to improve
the way John Michael Schmitz has
improved the past two years I I'm
floored I think someone's getting a
starting center and it's going to be one
of my favorite picks of the draft when
he does come off the board the other one
juice Scruggs right a few Scruggs went
ahead of him too Scruggs are solid
um he went where did he go in the draft
of 61 I would have preferred whippler in
that conversation but I I again like I'm
not those are all starting centers also
like I think there were probably four in
this draft class that I had top uh 110
and what was the only one not to come
off the board so far yeah he's still
there so we'll see what happens with him
we are at pick number this is the 19th
pick of the fourth round pick number
121. so we've got goodness
I've got a handful of picks to go in
this in this fourth round and then we're
moving on to the onto the on to the
fifth
halfway point almost we're 18 picks in
14 picks
to go
I do I do want to see so Daniel Jeremiah
tweeted before this he said expect
quarterbacks to come off early
they have not there's not been one to
come off in this fourth round but but I
am curious to see so I prefer Tanner
McKee because of kind of what we broke
down earlier but I know jiren Hall is in
that mix to come off the board the BYU
quarterback DTR Dorian Thompson Robinson
the UCLA quarterback with Chris Sims is
unbelievably high on Adam like his
fourth QB all right and then also uh
gosh last one is uh
Jake hayner from Fresno State it could
all be possibilities come off the board
here soon this is a guy like vintro
Miller ventro Miller out of Florida I
think he's just a good linebacker
obviously I know he's in the he's going
in the fourth round the 19th pick of the
fourth round pick number 121. he's a kid
that played at Florida played a lot of
football at Florida he's he's he I think
he's got the opportunity to be uh at
every down starting linebacker in the
NFL and that we just talked about value
if you can get that guy in the fourth
round then you're doing something right
I think he's definitely going to help
you on special teams but look at the way
he's able to run sideline to sideline I
love that about him you see him there
turn his hips in coverage and go get a
pdu that's a beautiful play right there
you don't see that very often what do
you think about ventrell this guy is a
straight line Dynamo I mean when he
wants to come downhill he will rock you
he has legit sideline and sideline speed
he's a touch stiff for my liking when
you ask him to flip his hips run down
the football field change directions in
space I don't think you're ever getting
much of a high-end coverage linebacker
but he's a guy who can make an impact as
a Blitzer he's a guy that can play the
run at a high level and obviously play
it against the highest level competition
at Florida I will though just say of
note was at one point dismissed from the
Florida program back in 2019 So that
obviously could factor into why he is
still available at this point draft yeah
next up do we got the there we go let's
do it the Arizona Cardinals
they select
John Gaines the UCLA office you see a
guard or tackle guard that's a guard
yeah he's a little undersized that's you
know the biggest issue with him six foot
four 303 play strength a bit of an issue
but he's one of the best athletes in
this draft class he had a four four five
short shuttle his ability to mirror
quickness on the interior some of the
best in his draft class I believe he had
the fastest short shuttle and the
fastest three cone of any interior
lineman at the combine that's what you
want in terms of pass protection right
that is that is what translates to the
NFL in that regard is just positioning
the ability to stay in front of guys I
don't think you're ever getting a
high-end run blocker out of a guy like
John Gaines I just don't see him having
that level of physicality that he plays
with but
you got to protect Kyler right you see
right there that is what you are
drafting him for and this is the point
where you find starting guards uh more
often than not these guys are playing on
your football team and it's still
valuable to find them so I I like what
the Cardinals have done here they're
really addressing this offensive line
and trying to make sure that Kyler
Murray and that ACL doesn't happen again
he's help he's helping with that I mean
he's he's creating creatures for what
was a very very impressive UCLA Run game
and finding a way to create space for
people here we go next up we've got the
Seahawks taking DT Cameron young out of
Mississippi State this guy is a he's a
host dude like he plays big time he's
got heavy hands yes this is a
one of the better athletes in this DT
class he said heavy hands he has big
hands 10 inch hands a six foot ten inch
wingspan 34 and a half inch arms like he
is a block controller is how I described
it he's the guy who was going to two Gap
or one long Army and just go left or
right on you I don't think he offers
much in the way of pass rushing I don't
see the twitch the lateral agility to
kind of Shimmy Shake to kind of get
around you but as far as Silo Run
Defenders there aren't a ton better in
this draft class to me I had him higher
than a guy in Byron young who went
probably a full round earlier the
Alabama defensive tackle I just think
he's a more projectable NFL athlete to
that position for what he's going to be
asked to do so I'm a fan of this pick
his arms are longer than I remember them
being like just re-watching this his
arms are a lot longer than I remember
but he's still I think he still plays
with good leverage even though he does
have some longer arms yeah he plays low
four size
um and again you're looking at these are
these are role players that are coming
off the board here these aren't guys
that short yardage exactly this first
down this is a guy that can play a-roll
for you and you feel comfortable in him
doing so on your roster yeah goal line
like that's he fits in there okay we got
the Ravens the Ravens who are they
picking
Robinson okay
where do you have him on your board he
was a little lower down my board I get
why he comes off here unique build 66
257 and like looks like a wide receiver
right there you see that that is a long
lanky that is what Edge position is and
so he takes those boxes tested well at
the combine 466 uh 40 with a 158 10
split those are good numbers I just
worry stiff this guy struggles to
consistently play low at six foot six
it's hard to sink into contact
consistently and he just does not have
the sort of you see him trying to bend
yeah he looks a little rough yeah he
doesn't have that to his game so I
accomped him to DJ wanum who's obviously
was a mid-rounder for the Vikings a few
years ago which is kind of
he's a guy that can probably early down
against the run I'm not sure I ever
expect him to be too much as a pure pass
rusher but the Ravens and how they've
developed edges wouldn't put it past
them there you go the Ravens in this
draft so far they have taken safe
flowers that's a home run they're taking
Trenton Simpson that feels like it's
going to be a pretty solid pick for them
and then obviously now we add in tavius
Robinson feels weird that the Ravens
don't have like 10 third and fourth
round picks right they have the last
couple of years but they they went out
and spent some they traded it and spent
some money so they're making some plays
though they've gotta they've got they've
got the same pick pick 22. that was pick
22 at the fourth round there's the same
pick in the fifth round here we go pick
us in what do we got
this the whole gang of Texas wide
receivers from SMU Houston
like
this guy is fast this is a return man
they just picked a return man this is
why you're drafting which is interesting
I mean because 531 yards last year that
was a career high and that was yeah in
terms of reception he's not a he's not a
part of your offense he is
you know purely Return Man but he's a
pretty damn good one right he ran a four
three six forty coming out the combine
he is Twitchy dude is wound up PE can
move but again this is you're drafted
him purely as a returner or maybe a pure
Gadget guy in the offense bring him in
run them on deep crossers that sort of
thing and maybe you can hit a splash
play every now and then but uh truly a
like I said interesting point to be
taking those guys at with guys like
maybe Tyler Scott still on the board the
Cincinnati wide receiver who has legit
starting potential this guy's probably
would be very floored if he ever starts
in the office yet he's only a five foot
nine inch Wing speed yeah you know like
yeah that would be the smallest here in
the NFL he's a gadget piece we talked
about it we talked about it a little
while ago when do you when you start
drafting special teams guys you can get
a guy that right now right now I mean
this guy averaged 15 yards per per
return two two touchdowns he scored a
year ago or this past season I mean he
gets to he he understands his assignment
he knows what he's supposed to do and
when you look at him play he is electric
and when you work if you can work him
into some of those Jet Sweep that jet
action working into some of those under
those little shallow crosses you've got
something on your on their board you
look at what the Chargers have been able
to do today Quentin Johnston okay that's
going to be one of your big time wide
receivers Tuli Tui puloto he's going to
help you out along that front Diane
Henley I think you think he's gonna play
Early yes yeah okay and then Jerry's
Davis there's Davis guess what he's
going to get to camp and they're going
to be like hey man just go over there
with the specialist catch punts catch
kickoffs I didn't even look at what do
you do did he do anything in kick
returns too yeah no touchdowns but I
mean the average 20 yards of per kick
return so I think he's gonna be okay
this this Chargers draft is probably one
of my favorites of anyone okay now
obviously you're leading and gravitate
towards the teams that just picked eight
guys in the first three rounds and they
got a zillion Got Talented dudes but as
far as pick for pick goes those first
three I'd stack up with anyone because I
we both love Quentin Johnson we gushed
about him on day one yes but then I love
Diane Henley yeah I think he is what
they are missing now with obviously uh
losing uh the former Notre in linebacker
on blanket on his name but uh Drew
tranquil so I'm a big fan of his uh he
immediately fills issues and now they do
have Eric Hendricks there who they
brought over but I'm starting Diane
Henley over Kenneth Murray I'm just
telling you right now I don't think
that's really a fair fight there we go
all right on the clock right now we've
got the Browns we've already seen the
Browns make a pick this uh they picked
DeJuan Jones already this uh this round
so they're at pick 24 pick 126 overall
we got we're looking at the big board
some interesting new names there towards
the back that I'm surprised are still
here one is Corey Trice this guy's tape
last year was awesome and he is a horse
of a corner have we had any Purdue
players come off the board yet I don't
believe I don't think so right yeah but
he's he was their best Prospect at 73 on
the board and he's a high-end athlete
too though I mean he is six foot two
over 200 pounds Sierra 673 cone at that
size which is unique that
if you're a press any sort of team this
guy should be high on your boards now
maybe he is just a press corner and
that's why he falls here and maybe
that's why we saw like Joey Porter Falls
the second round for similar reasons
because not a lot of teams are going
that route anymore it's becoming an off
coverage league but if you still play
press this guy can start for you this
guy can start for you year one we got
another we got one guy coming off your
board oh do we yeah we got Missouri Oh
Isaiah McGuire defensive Infamous Zoo so
look at that they're killing it coming
off the board I I I like this guy top 75
player on board because his flexibility
you don't see a lot of 270 Pounders so
he's he's a big dude yeah he's he is a
guy who is a powerful defensive end six
foot four 268 34 inch arms you know a
6-10 Wing spam and he can dip around the
edge he had a 7193 cone you know that's
better than some of the wide receivers
that's better than Quentin Johnston yeah
that came off the board in the
first round wide receiver like this guy
can move around the edge he gave
Broderick Jones fits and his ability to
stick in his tracks in the Run game and
really set a hard Edge this is a guy
that's going to start early Downs for
them because they don't have someone now
across from Miles Garrett that they feel
good about in that role I think day one
he can provide that
um reminded me of like a Kingsley and
agree who came out last year I think
he's a little bit better against the Run
even though than Kingsley is so this is
this is a good damn good pick the Browns
are really hitting some guys that can
make an impact on their team without
having a first and second round pick in
the shoe strap yeah 126 they're getting
the 75th best player on your board I
think that means a lot so this is going
to be really interesting to see how it
shakes itself up I think we've just had
a trade I believe so if we get that
information at some point but yeah I
just saw it looked like somebody
suggested there's a trade yep
Jacksonville trades to New Orleans so
New Orleans is now back on the clock
this is going to be interesting New
Orleans so far this round has drafted Oh
if we're talking about fifth retainers
I'd love New Orleans to take a
quarterback at this point in time
just interesting yeah oh I would love
for them to pick Tanner McKee yes or
like any QB at this point in the draft
just because
you got to give yourself options right I
think the Raiders found out the hard way
that just pigeonholing yourself to one
Derek Carr for as long as they did yeah
was not wise and now you're in a
position where the nfc's weak the
division especially at their end is week
that it's up for grabs for sure
but you're 127. you know get get a
quarter like a quarterback swing here is
well worth it and I feel better about
all these guys that I did freaking Ian's
book when they draft them in the fourth
quarterback
painter Jake hayner here we go Jake
kainer from Fresno State from Washington
to Fresno State played with a good
teaching this is something I love he's
not the most athletic guy does not have
the most strong arm but he knows how to
put the ball where it needs to be I'm a
huge fan of his
um played for Ted for Tedford is one of
my favorite quarterback coaches in the
history of football uh he's well taught
he does not make mistakes uh biggest
problem for him this season was injuries
right yes dealing with that with dealing
with that art we're dealing with that
leg injury he couldn't move when he
couldn't move he got teed off on because
their offensive line wasn't great but I
love Jake hainer what do you think about
him yeah he scored really well in the S2
test I know as well but the size is why
you know injury combined with being six
foot 207 is like yeah is he gonna get
hurt but I love this guy Pro Comp
there's Taylor heinecke in terms of that
okay because he's a gamer he shows off
when it matters I go back to that UCLA
game a couple years ago when they upset
him he had a drive at the end where it
was just all him you know a drive that's
better than anything we've seen to this
point from
CJ Stroud and clutch situations from
Anthony Richardson in collector
situation from will Levinson clutch
situations like it was a big boy drive
and as she held off on my guy though
Bryce went in big game situations but he
has that on film already I do worry
about how he handles pressure though at
that size he he throws a lot off his
back foot yes he does he will get a
little bit skittish when something comes
there but he he said he doesn't have a
great arm like this is an NFL arm though
I'd put his arm on par with someone like
Bryce young and CJ stride like it's in
that realm of arm strength I think and
spin it I think it's not the strength
for me I think he I don't think he has
the same strength as those guys but I do
think he has a quicker release and he's
more accurate than all of them than the
most yeah he's more he's certainly more
active than Anthony Richardson yeah
there you go he's incredible he's
remarkably accurate he does her off his
back foot because he's trying to avoid
pressure trying to avoid getting hit
because he needs to stay healthy for
them to win football games and then he
but I love the way that he can change
his arm slot up and down up and down and
still be remarkably accurate could be a
good QB has promised thank you dilton
Paul uh Alicia I love the spot for QB if
it works out gold if not nothing nothing
really lost I totally agree with you
that's why this is the pick we're very
happy with it this is really going to be
fun I think that the reality here is
they got a guy that what's the worst
case scenario he's your backup yeah I
mean it needed a backup there obviously
no more Andy Dalton but I I did I did
think after Tanner McGee was my next
quarterback available oh here we go the
lions are trading starting running back
DeAndre Swift sources tell me and Tom
pellissario are sending him to the
Eagles lefco oh my I wish lefko was here
huh what is going on it exchange our
traffic compensation with David with
David Montgomery and now Jamir Gibbs
Swift heads out okay
Swift is good he is good Swift swift is
a damn good football but apparently he
from everything that we've heard they
just they were big butted heads oh him
induce daily we're gonna fight at some
point if you watched Hard Knocks at all
they just he he does not run the way do
Staley runs and that's the problem he is
a guy who is continually searching for
that bounce house for that space and in
the NFL level the space is rarely
sweeter than it looks right it's a
Fool's Gold to try to get that space on
the outside because these DNS run four
fours they'll track you down so that's
the problem with him but you have Rashad
Penny who can be your between the tax
guy shot penny is awesome his vision and
running in that area of the field is as
good as he gets this is your third down
back this is your pass catcher this is
your screen guy and in that role dude
he's like a top 10 back in the NFL in
that role there really aren't too many
better than him in such a and that's
like ah man man yeah
mean what the Eagles are just absolutely
out here just
they're they're they
they took the they realized we almost
won a Super Bowl so let's do everything
we can to win the Super Bowl and here's
the thing down or Swift's no worse than
when you got picked in the second round
right he's still that good and it's why
we say like don't pick them that high
here we go oh wow that's in first night
oh wow
Ram's taking them the Rams have selected
QB Stetson Bennett from Georgia did you
see him going before any of those other
three guys
I quite frankly did not but I did have I
had a fourth round after his day this is
the realm I thought he would go I
thought maybe those other guys might go
a little earlier but I like him his tape
was good he played damn good football
now he is you know everyone knows he's
25 years old we get it but he's an
athlete at four six seven forty he's
faster than that he jogged out that 40th
combine but 511 192 I mean you're just
never really gonna start this guy with
confirms Doug Flutie Doug Flutie won
some games in the NFL for this reason
right here you can make a little magic
dude he plays the game well like the
right way has an NFL caliber arm it's
not weak like it's I think it's like a
stronger arm than even like a Joe burrow
maybe it's not bad by any means but it's
not going to be described as good but
when it came crunch time the dude did
not blink over the last season and a
half it truly did not and so as much as
the town around him was pretty nasty at
Georgia
he didn't
he didn't may not have elevated it but
he facilitated it so
I think someone said I I thought
someone's put it succinctly saying
Georgia could have won the National
Championship without John Carter they
weren't going to win Nash Championship
without sets of that yeah so here's
here's my take
early on when he first got the start
out of necessity I was not impressed
yeah I'll be honest I I saw it in high
school I know why they call him the
mailman because I was there at the
openings when he was running around in
the U.S Postal Service hat
I remember that
he was he was in Atlanta I think he was
in Houston maybe at one more too or
maybe it was New Orleans but I remember
that I was like excuse me one of these
things doesn't look like the other and
it was in the same year as guys like I
don't know it was a Tanner McKee or
Trevor Lawrence or that one of these
things doesn't look like the other and
then
the next thing you know
gets into that second year and then it
gets going and I was like okay this kid
can play he he won he truly won me over
like I'm not ashamed to admit that I
didn't believe him at first he didn't
look like what he didn't look like any
of the other guys and then he truly came
around he grew on me he's a good
quarterback this guy can play I don't
like to use the term gamer but at the
end of the day he understands what he
needs to do to succeed he puts his team
and this is what I love
he saw this Georgia team come around to
believe in him too what they let him do
early on in his career versus what they
let him do at the back end of his career
four Worlds Apart we're talking screens
shallow passes that's what we're talking
about early and then we start to see him
be able to push the ball up and over the
top so I'm a Believer let's go I truly
think the second half in the national
championship game against Alabama he
turned into a different player after
that that was like pre pre-90 Stetson
Bender versus postnay sets and men who
were two different people you know him
going on TV the next day hammered uh on
what was it good morning America that
was the start of a new Stetson Bennett
and truly the guy we saw this past year
was a legitimate NFL quarterback it
truly was it was maybe not a starter but
it was a guy who can play in the league
even if a lot of people before that
thought he wasn't even a legitimate
college quarterback yeah that's the
point is he he absolutely can he can
play in the NFL
oh my goodness Where Are we almost the
back end of fourth he goes he goes by by
the way I figured out what what cap was
saying in my ear he goes to Matt
Stafford's there
Matt Stafford's there so now we have a
little bit of dogs West
with with Bennett and staff the two best
QBs in Georgia football history
keeps you fat
I mean
heard rumors about cook
don't know oh who would I want here for
the Cowboys for the Cowboys I would love
someone like Amoro ajomo there like add
to that d-line keep building it up right
you know one Mozzy Smith's cool keep
giving yourself options on the interior
is that where I think I'd go if I were
them
yeah
I
I'm trying to look at their needs and
they're clapping they love it okay they
like it but they clap every time though
actually Jerry's still on the phone
they do clap every time the clap every
time all right let's see what the
Cowboys have done so they don't have the
electricity of the Lions war room after
a pick
all right what we got
Oh Billy Army let's go top 100 player on
my board oh yes oh absolutely this guy
his tape is it's fun he's fun that's
like the only way to describe it because
he doesn't have what we'd call traits
that like that the NFL loves he's six
foot four 280 280. playing on the Edge
at San Jose State but he's powerful he
reminds me stylistically of a zadarius
Smith and that's big Z was at this point
in the draft too I think he was a fourth
or fifth rounder coming out of Kentucky
where he's just he's not linear he's not
super explosive in a straight line he's
not super quick but all he needs is one
paw to land and he knocks you to the
side a little because he's so powerful
and then he kind of just skirts past you
and gets the ball carriers I I this guy
was Uber productive at San Jose State
multiple seasons of it this past year
nine sacks 19 tackles for loss
um this is this is what I just mentioned
this is a guy that can stop the run for
your football team on early downs and
truly can be an interior Pass Restaurant
third Downs I love this pick I love this
fit and
Cowboys like I said are continue to add
to this d-line in ways I love yeah
they're building up this defensive line
I Love Field goes so Good by the way
cousin of vitavia oh yes I know that
yeah everybody thinks he's related to
the fiocos he's not yeah right he's a
Vega guy so
um really watching him play he's all
over the field he is someone that at one
point that's why I said he's 280 because
he plays he looked smaller than that and
but he because he moved moved to the
ends here moved to the exterior he moved
off the ball played Standing Up played
hand down he could do a lot of different
things tremendous versatility we're
looking at the Cowboys draft right now
mozzie Smith we know Michael Parsons was
thrilled about that Schoonmaker who
we've talked about already over shown
we've talked about him I'm curious to
see how overshawn slots in there they
got a lot of linebackers they got a lot
of linebackers real Cox Damon Clark who
they drafted recently to yeah so and
then fioco fioco's gonna obviously step
up to play in that line in that rotation
and he's gonna go up and make some play
so we got Jaguars too their pick is
coming through let's see what they do
boom Jags who are the Jags picking
oh Tyler Lacy the okay State yeah look
at that
Tyler Lacey from Oklahoma State
this guy similar players to him in
fahoka right yes that's what I was I was
gonna say what's I don't know what the
difference is between them with the
exception of fijoco seems to have a more
be more powerful the production is the
difference in my opinion the laces a
similarly tooled guy you know and even
their testing was similar but just I did
not see enough twitch with him to be
able to impact the passing again like he
is a pure run down defensive end whereas
I thought for hoko like as an interior
rusher you might have a little something
from him I don't think he got that from
Lacey he went down the Senior Bowl down
to mobile and truly like he got blocked
up he was not making much of an impact
in the one-on-ones which is always to me
a red flag because those are those are
set up to be defensive line you're
supposed to you're the d-line are
supposed to win yeah for those that
don't know
one-on-ones both on the defense
one-on-ones between the offensive line
and defensive line are set up for the
defender to win yeah one-on-ones between
wide receivers and defensive backs are
set up for wide receivers if you were
losing those reps
then you are you're lacking in some area
whether it's moves strength
understanding of what's going on like
you don't like if you can't understand
how to play through the outside half of
a player instead of running straight
into them that's a thing that you got it
you you clearly haven't been taught
correctly and you've got it you're gonna
have to learn and here's where he's
lacking so 279 that's it that's a 4-3
defensive end or a 3-4 defensive end
he's not an interior guy
five one one forty oh no and 763 cone
now we did do 30 bench press reps like
he's strong he can hold up in the
running game sure but you're just
getting a bit of a limited player at
this point yeah yeah so let's let's talk
more about the one-on-one situation
because you you go down there what
impresses you when uh how when how does
that offensive lineman win in that spot
that impresses you
I think
coordination is what I'm looking for for
offensive lineman down there because a
lot of times on tape and past protection
you are like you're protected right
you're part of a unit you yeah you can
say I I don't care about Inside Moves I
have the slide coming my way my left
guard is going to help on any inside
right uh and that's the vast majority of
pass back drop back passing snaps for
offensive lineman but there you are
truly on an island and so a lot of times
you'll see inside moves or pure bull
rushes that like you don't see in a game
in the game usually and so how do you
react how do your hands and feet work in
unison are you ready then to play in the
NFL and it really kind of exposes who is
and who isn't and again when a guy like
Tyler Lacey goes there and just doesn't
make an impact it's a pass rusher that's
a worrisome thing here we go pick is in
oh I love this fit the Bengals take wide
receiver Charlie Jones out of Purdue a
guy that you want to talk about
production I mean this guy
constantly produce constantly open don't
know how how did you forget him he's the
best player he's the best pass catcher
that they have I don't understand he's
how he was always open this is this is
basically I compare him to I think Jared
Abbrederis he is reliable as can be I
think he had the lowest drop rate of any
wide receiver in this draft class if it
is possible for him to haul it in he is
going to haul it in tremendous hands the
only worry is five years
five years it took him to even see the
football field I think it was three
years at Buffalo two years at Iowa
transfers to Purdue for a sixth season
and all of a sudden goes for 110 catches
1361 yards and as you see there making
big plays on the outside making big
plays over Corners like Garrett Williams
that came off the board in the third
round that are not easy to make like
that right there was insane the guy was
great concentration
and I think he's a Shifty router the
only problem is 175 pounds he is a slot
but they're looking for a transition
plan from Tyler Boyd obviously he's a
big contract coming up soon getting up
there in age I think this is your slot
wide receiver once Tyler Boyd
um is elsewhere yeah he's but here's the
thing for me if you can hide him in the
slot then he's going to be okay I'm not
worried about his size nearly as much
and he's super Shifty right he does not
let himself get hit he doesn't he's
never takes a big hit he understands
where he needs to be look he's like no
no no no no no no that big guy's not
going to get his paws on me and he's not
the fastest he doesn't have to be they
catch up to him okay guess what I got
all these yards we are now in winning
we're a winning position we're in
position to go out and make plays
um you look at the skill positions
obviously jamarchas T Higgins Tyler Boyd
you add in Charlie Jones Charlie Jones
is going to walk into that room he's
going to learn from these guys he's
going to figure out what he needs to do
to be in the NFL he's got it's taking
him a long road to get here and so you
look at those guys when they had last
year like when they were without Higgins
when they were without case their wide
receiver four was an issue whoever it
was coming in onto that football field
for the most part Jones now will not be
an issue right he you can he is going to
be reliable he's not going to be
coughing up easy ones he's not going to
be in the wrong spot this guy that
may never be you know a wide receiver
two or a wide receiver one sure but he's
a wide receiver 300 football team right
he's good he's a good football I love I
loved watching him play this year
because
it seems like I don't know how many I
don't know how much you can watch of a
guy on film
and pretend like he's not good oh it's
hard to I mean 1300 yards you can't fake
that like with the way he was playing
like how do you how do you watch this
this guy on film week in week out if
you're in Nebraska if you're if you're
if you're Ohio State if you're any of
these teams and not think oh he's good
we need to pay attention to him we need
to worry about him we need to check on
him we need to make sure we know where
he is on every single play and to me
truly disrespectful but also like it
speaks to what he's able to do because
maybe they were paying attention to him
he was just so good it didn't matter
yeah Jones is a player uh that this is a
fun pick for the Bengals they had an
interesting draft because they're
they're Forward Thinking none of these
guys you know everyone's like oh o-line
o-line these are all guys that if we
lose free agents they can step up and
play in those spots oh here we go
Steelers they did it unbelievable the
this is a guy I wanted to go there that
that was the spot for him because he can
Rush that's a scheme so this is a true
3-4 outside linebacker coming out of it
yes he is he is six two 240 with under
32 inch arms that that's not a profile
that a lot of people love for success of
the NFL level rush in the pastor but he
gets off the football he is slippery
into contact he knows how to adjust his
Pad level to avoid that big blow that
stops him in his tracks and then he uses
his hands so well this is a red shirt
sophomore coming out yeah we're talking
about Charlie Jones who's 24 60 or dude
this is a young guy still ascending
who's played elite football the last two
years and not just good he was dominant
in the Big Ten beating guys like Paris
Johnson on tape and now you just worry
about traits projecting the next level
but he's got some undersized guys there
in Alex High Smith and TJ Watts you can
learn from who have figured out how to
win consistently at a high level as pass
rushers with similar tool sets with
similar skill sets and man
uh this is an absolute the Steelers is
huge take their drafting of Brothers to
another level now because Nate herbig on
the roster there they drafted obviously
um cam hayward's Brother last year
absolutely love love the twins before
that on the offensive line
the kids from Florida oh yeah the
pounces
so it's this is just one of those things
where you watch this and you see what
they're able to do he's well you see
what he's able to do quick move of
stutter I love that little stutter step
right there and then quick move to get
inside he can get outside he can win on
the edge and he's tough he's tough he's
physical you know he is he played at
Wisconsin that's what they are that's
all they do that's all they make that's
what they create and so this is going to
be really fun to see how he grows up
into this I his brothers his brother's
in the NFL yeah yeah like her big
brothers in the NFL he played football
at Stanford he plays offensive line so
this is one of those things where
it does matter when you have family
members that are in the NFL you do you
do get a leg up whether it's your dad or
your uncle or your cousin or your
brother like it helps because you
understand how hard you have to work to
stay in it you don't just walk in and
think I'm the man you walk in and think
they're going to do everything they can
to get me out of here and what I love
how I describe her big to a friend when
I was discussing him was he's too good
at football to be bad in the NFL like
there's so many knocks against them in
the size and the length and the limited
athleticism he plays the game already
too well to be bad and I even loved him
it's an off-ball linebacker transition
if you wanted to because I thought he
understood the game well enough to make
that transition there's still a
possibility yeah they had you know Joe
schobert playing off ball there at one
time who was a similar sort of prospect
coming out of Wisconsin
oh finally get a wide receiver coming
off the board in Tyler Scott look at
that Cincinnati wideout I expected him
to go a lot earlier than this because
4 4 speed legit deep production on tape
and 44 speed truthfully like I don't
think did him a service like he looks
faster than that on tape GPS times that
were faster than that and a guy who was
a running back and a cornerback in high
school only started playing wide
receiver really when he got to
Cincinnati and you're on your
progression you saw it from year one
tier two to year three and I think he's
Shifty after the catch to make plays
with the ball in his hands to where
man what does this guy get to next you
know he's young he can have some
development to his game that other guys
can't especially when he's as physically
gifted as you see here on tape to where
Chicago Bears now have darno Mooney
Chase Claypool and him that can all
really get down the football field they
had to hold real speed to challenge and
that's how I want this office to be
built I'd even give this guy some
carries out of the backfield because as
I was saying we need some speed there in
that backfield in Chicago I would mess
around and throw him a few jet sweeps
every time every now and then so here we
go I'm gonna I'm gonna read them for you
you're in 2020 for him three catches for
20 yards no touchdowns one rushing yard
20 one rushing attempt 20 yards 20 21 30
catches that's a huge 10 times more
catches 523 yards five touchdowns five
carriers 102 yards on the ground no
touchdowns and then we get to 2022 this
past season what does he do 54 catches
for 900 yards
nine touchdowns and then he also has oh
and they then they oh
they didn't let him run the ball he was
just a wide receiver for all last year
that's about Cincinnati stock last year
come on pick no it was it was a very
like he's a good football like okay you
mentioned the fact that we like Gadget
pieces we like guys that can run we like
guys that can make plays and he can do
all those things he's got the ability to
really
take the top off of a defense be a
threat down the field and that's what
we're looking for because if you have
that now all things things can start
open up in the Run game things to start
or vice versa because the teams are
worried about Justin Fields running the
football and that safety comes down
right behind him and so we had two guys
in Trey Tucker and Darius Davis come off
the board who I called probably just
Gadget guys who are like small Sports
guys
Scott's a small speed guy but he has
like a 6-1 wingspan he has legitimate
ability to make plays and still be an
option in your offense high-end athlete
who can also return so I'm surprised
those guys go before someone like Scott
because Scott can
stop Scott can be a one or two in your
offense in time there's that potential
with him whereas those guys I just don't
see it to me he wasn't too dissimilar of
a prospect to Jalen Hyatt now I know
highest production was there and he's
more advanced in a lot of ways as a
receiver but they're similarly tooled
athletes well there we go
and now we got the Vikings looks like
the yep there it is
hey LSU safety wow Jay Ward did you
think it would go this High I did
actually I had a fourth round grade on
him coming out of LSU I think he's I
love his length you know he's six foot
188 Pounds with 32 and a half inch arms
that's he played a lot of slot at LSU
that's probably where I'd play him in
the NFL and now where'd he come off the
board too here we got to the Vikings
okay I came to the Vikings at picks 32
134 overall so this is a guy I'd feel
comfortable dropping down and playing
man coverage over the slot I think he
has that sort of ability to him because
455 speed is just it's not the range you
want for a back end player I I don't
think that's ever going to be his game
to me he looked more like a cornerback
than a safety on tape so with Ryan
Flores now obviously bringing over uh
his predominantly Blitz and Man heavy
defense that he's played a lot over the
years
I think this is probably a slot in your
defense yeah it's a good throw in that
player beats him goodness yeah I I liked
him I didn't know if they were using him
correctly and hearing your answer on
that that makes a little more sense
because they did have him in the back
end some when he was he was better
coming down better in the slot yes
better better especially guys not afraid
to mix it up against the Run 6-1 188 he
is thin that is a that's a thin guy but
he'll mix it up and we saw in that that
clip both a couple times when he after
he made a hit or he got hit he did lay
down for a little while so he's a guy
that's you got to watch him and see make
sure his durability stays up this is the
last pick of the round the Patriots are
on the clock
well that's Jay Ward yeah like I just
pass this is it
Pat's draft so far should we reset the
patch draft yeah oh we got to trade oh
okay wait let's not reset the pass let's
reset the best graders Vegas back in at
round four at pick 135 Vegas is back in
what are they looking for so they went
and they're the one that went Trey
Tucker earlier Las Vegas has picked up
jacorian Bennett Trey Tucker today they
also got Byron Young
yesterday Michael Mayer yesterday Tyree
Wilson Thursday
really a you know when you think of some
drafts that have scenes when we talked
about the Steelers draft being like a
toughness yeah get back to a draft this
is a draft that's hard to like figure
out truthfully they went with Tyree
Wilson was kind of like a pick that
picks itself in the top ten sure we need
that let's get that mayor then in the
second round how he fits into Stephen
core I'd be excited to see young then
was just like two Gap run Defender a
little something different but then then
a gadget return guy and then a
then a corner with just pure speed it's
an interesting like if you're going for
like toughness physicality that makes
sense until we go Trey Tucker to Cory
and Bennett right if you're going for
like dynamism well those first
three guys don't really have this aren't
those so kind of discombob kind of just
no Rhyme or Reason here but uh they got
a few players that I like especially
Wilson Amer but that's like the draft
will be remembered by your first two
picks more often than not especially for
two picks the rest don't really matter
especially if mayor becomes you know of
your franchise is best you're you're
facing your franchise you're tied in
that you've you throw the ball to yes
four or five times a game you pick he's
always picking up first downs and you
can always count on them and they
welcome respite for Raiders fans who
usually it was the opposite first and
second round pick sucked yeah and then
Mike mayak took over and all of a sudden
oh we got a hunter Renfro oh we got a
Max Crosby no now they're picking the
good guys first thankful that's where
you that's where you want to be picking
uh the impact players on your roster
there's this is not deers Hayward Bay
this thing Cleveland furl fourth overall
oh man I why didn't he Panic sadly well
I mean well quite frankly because it
wasn't that good even as a prospect but
low end athletes right I mean low-end
athletes along the defensive line they
just look better in college than they do
in the NFL more often than that I put
him in a similar category too uh who's
the guy left goes to cry Derek Barnett
out of Tennessee where it's just like
man you got to have juice in the NFL
tackles are athletic tackles know how to
use their hands so if you just have
hands and without Elite length and
without Elite burst chances are those
hands are going to look a lot better
against Collegiate tackles than they do
NFL tackles sure because most Collegiate
tackles don't play in the NFL there you
go
yeah
all right picks in what do we got
Raiders I'm trying to think who they
would even go with here oh QB is coming
out
is this
wow two Purdue guys in the in the third
round fourth round excuse me you know if
you can get past a little bit of a funky
release that Aiden O'Connell has it's
easy to be a fan of his game and now it
kind of dumps it down low and then kind
of like tucks
it's like a dropping like yeah not ideal
but he he was a guy who was just trying
to keep his head above water with the
town around him at Purdue like there's a
offensive line Tower yeah there's a
reason he would just go to Charlie Jones
there as you saw us because no one else
was getting open and he didn't have time
really to go to anyone else but he's a
guy who works with timing really well if
he didn't get the ball of his hands
quickly he was getting crushed so he got
the ball out of his hands quickly I
think he has an NFL caliber arm even if
it's nothing special and and I love that
he keeps bouncing back like he will make
one to two plays a game that you're like
what the hell was that Throne he will
throw one up for grabs but then it won't
affect him he won't fall off and he
won't spiral into you know a complete
disaster game he had games where he
threw a lot of picks but he didn't have
games where he was completely
ineffective right like he at least
showed up every single week yeah I love
I think he's a good player this is
someone who just again as you mentioned
he showed up every single week he was
able to get the job done he was able I
mean realistically let me see I'm gonna
look this up the Purdue game against
they played Michigan this year and they
lost Big Ten Championship
and this is the this is he had him in
that game in the first half yes before
yes he threw two interceptions and that
was the difference then he started then
he then he kind of heave went up there
that was the difference in that game but
he threw against this Mission defense
that everybody called so great 32 for
47.
four Thirty for 37 366 yards he didn't
throw any TVs that's what they needed
yep and that was that was a big problem
they had a spot in that game late that
they were within a score and if he could
have gotten them a TD instead of an
interception they would have been in a
bit they would have been in business so
I like that folks we have reached the
end of the third round of BR Gridiron
draft night coverage we're gonna do a
recap of round four this is fourth round
of the draft 33 picks let's take a look
at them here we go some notable picks
we've got Stetson Benning from Georgia
going to the Chart going to the Chargers
we've got Vilma via viliami fioco from
San Jose State he's headed to the
Cowboys that's a good pick we both we
all like that pick dude uh Tyler Lacy
Oklahoma State uh defensive lineman
going to the Jacks Charlie Jones wide
receiver from Purdue headed to the
Bengals Nick herbig linebacker Edge
rusher from the from Wisconsin he's
headed to the Steelers Tyler Scott from
from what from Cincinnati he's a wide
receiver he's got a weapon for the Bears
Jay Ward and LSU safety headed to the
Vikings and Aiden O'Connell the final
pick of the draft of the fourth round go
to Purdue or excuse me coming from
Purdue to go play for the Raiders uh
we're looking at the big board Now take
us to the big board let's see what we
got so I'm surprised McKee some of these
guys getting drafted quite frankly now I
knew he was going to go at this point in
the draft and quarterbacks I'm just
going to be higher on some than most
when you're that's how it goes
whippler is if anyone's a surprise to
still be available come fifth round it's
him that's the starting center in the
NFL I am floored that he is still yeah
on the board at this point in time some
of my favorite picks from round four
I'll kick it right off from the top Nick
Sal davary yeah the New Orleans Saints I
think he's a starter for them at some
point in time I loved Keeley Ringo to
the Eagles I think everyone's gonna say
they love Keeley Eagles Hard to debate
that one I loved auditamiwa adabare
Jones to the Colts fantastic pick Juwan
Jones to the Cleveland Browns a little
further down the board Chandler Zavala
to the Carolina Panthers item is a top
65 player in this draft class he goes
all the way at 114 one of my favorite
picks for the Panthers in this class
going a little bit further down here I
really like The Pick of Nick Herbert to
the Steelers this Steelers draft when we
talk winners and losers who had the best
draft Steelers is going to be in the top
three top three grades I give out
because that has been an absolute haul
for them and really a draft that was
needed this team has had gotten depleted
in terms of young up-and-coming Talent
there was no watt in the pipeline there
was no Hayward in the pipeline now we
may have that with the Pittsburgh
Steelers let's kick it off we are going
to look high Trail Clark is that who God
I don't know I didn't see the name
oh Abdul oh Yasir Abdullah here we go
let's go I didn't see that I didn't see
that I didn't see the name I was like
there's gonna be one of those two those
are the two Louisville guys that are
probably coming off the board here soon
but abdullah's this is an athlete I mean
you don't see an edge rusher that far
down the football field making plays on
the football very often in 447 speed
that shows up on tape consistently 19
and a half sacks the past two seasons I
worry about a size if he is going to be
in Edge rusher like he was at Louisville
237 pounds
that's it we just talked about Nolan
Smith being that size and how it could
be an issue a duel does not play as
physical as Nolan Smith he wants to play
around blocks not through blocks as
opposed to Smith who loves the contact
relishes it so that's the word I have
with them I think here going to the
Jaguars he's either a situational pass
rusher or he's an off-ball linebacker
truthfully probably just a situational
Pass Restaurant in that room we look at
this look at this he can I think he can
be both right six one two thirty seven
four four forty he's got an opportunity
we got to trade I got a zillion
linebackers commanders on the on the
clock Buffalo trades 137 to Washington
for 150 and 215. okay Buffalo is working
back um they do have a lot of live
records but
with it with that speed and athleticism
maybe that's a skill set that he can
master and then in situational pass
rushing he can also then slide down and
do that yeah and at this point
especially team's value a guy who's that
big running a 447 coming down on a punt
team he's gonna get there in a hurry and
some some uh some special teams coaches
love that
so who's on the board on the clock
Washington thank you there we go Anders
the commanders are on the clock and they
did just go into your offensive lineman
early I was going to say could they be
moving up for one of these guys but I'm
curious to see who they do move up for
what's the desperation here I wouldn't
hate them going qb2 right just give
yourself options because the quarterback
there right now is Sam Sam Howell yeah
that's like kind of who you're if you're
banking on anything you should pick
Tanner McKee right here I mean that's
what I'm saying like just give yourself
another dude right on the Ross right now
Sam Howell Kobe Brissette
Jake ROM unfortunately
um yeah like a lot of meh a lot of
something that's just not super exciting
and now I'm not saying Tanner Makia so
sure if I slam dunk quarterback but it's
like when the Seahawks signs Matt Flynn
and then drafted Russell Wilson just
give yourself options because it doesn't
hurt to take those swings because Sam
how on the fifth last year do look good
at the end of the season you know like
there's uh they don't always fall
because of talent reasons some of these
quarterbacks in the draft
I'm curious to see what they do I mean
this is the picks in so what we're gonna
get to see
they are a the commanders are a team
that
is going to be
they're gonna be an interesting watch
this upcoming year quite frankly I
haven't loved their draft either up to
this point all right which Emmanuel
Forbes in the first Quan Martin in the
second Ricky Stromberg in the third and
then Brad Daniels was there KJ Henry
Clemson is the pick okay all right KJ
Henry is the top 100 player okay there
you go and you can get him if you can
get them at 130 137 that's a good one
pick is in let's see boom KJ Henry
defensive end out of Clemson this is a
guy that could just he when he when he's
on he's on yes he looks like he's a
little thin but he's very strong from
what I see out of the way that he plays
what do you think about that yeah unique
because at 250 you know six five 250 is
you would think under size but he's got
some pop to him yeah I mean he on
contact will hit you we'll rock you back
I think he is a three down type of
player I thought he was an average
Athlete on tape but he went to the
combine one four six three right you
know similar realm to Will Anderson so
this guy I I know he's a touch stiff
bending the edge but he works his hands
so well and that's how he wins that
I think he continued to do so at the NFL
level it's just another nice piece you
got your two edges there uh but how much
longer Chase young will be there after
they didn't pick up his fifth year
option remains to be seen this is a guy
that I I'm not saying is gonna ever be
the replacement for Chase young or a
starter but he's a guy that you like in
your rotation at defensive end if you
have one yeah uh KJ Henry also played at
West Forsyth High School that is the
last High School game that I played they
beat us in the playoffs he was a
five-star he was a high I know he was a
highly regular guy he's another one of
those North Carolina guys that ends up
outside of the state we are famous for
it to the Border close the wall Clemson
Georgia Florida they've all had guys
that were North Carolina guys make big
big plays for them
all right what do we got here
oh here we go Darius Rush South Carolina
corner he has some fans now I wasn't
particularly high on him like he had
people having him as a top 60 player in
this draft class like second round
grades I didn't see it because I think
he doesn't have the twitch out of his
brakes that I like to see to really like
drive on dig routes on stuff inside of
him and drive back down on footballs but
as a pure man Corner he's got that skill
set 6-2 198 he probably had you know the
corners at the Senior Bowl probably was
just behind tyreik Stevenson and Josh
Brens Julian Brent Julius Brent in terms
of his performance down there I think
he's really good at seeing uh receivers
breaks from a pure man covers
perspective so when he's staring at him
he reads their body language to know
when they're throttling down when
they're gonna sit when they're gonna
break off their route and kind of where
their stems going I did think from off
coverage he wasn't near the player but
for 6-2 with his length and 436 speed at
this point in the draft that's something
that I'm intrigued by at the very least
yeah I see the quadrant tankersley
comparison a guy from a different School
in South Carolina but certainly two two
players that are pretty young man
especially here's the thing
if he can get hands on you then he can
run with you if he can get hands on you
if he can sit in your hip pocket it's
and feel you then he can go play and
that's the cool thing about him even
right there with the little with the
little Zone turn he's able to feel him
behind him and he can go make a play
they're physical enough to strip that
ball out and
special teams we talked about it earlier
what are we looking for we're looking
for guys that can play special teams
there we go let's go so that's a that's
a great pick I like it a lot especially
for the idea that early on guess what
all I need you to do is be a gunner I
just need you to be a gunner go down
there and and go tackle upon it go go
tackle a punt returner and that's what I
need you to do so this is going to be
interesting the what do we have so he's
this is a culture the Colts draft now
Anthony Richardson
Julius brantz Josh Downs Blake Freeland
Ade adibare and now Darius Rush that's
that's as good a draft as I've seen from
them in a while you know they crushed it
they're they're kind of franchise
defying draft was the Quinton Nelson
Darius Leonard Shaq Leonard now draft
where they had multiple All Pro from one
draft that kind of set the tone but
since then the past few years has not
been as sweet they have not come nearly
close to that Chris Ballard has to me
this is a draft that can get there these
are guys that can get to high-end type
of performance for you that Colts fans
could be looking down the road you know
a few years from now looking back and
saying this was the start of our you
know turn around here okay I got a
surprise for you don't look don't look
don't look
tune yes to the Cardinals Arizona
Cardinals Jeff Clayton toon quarterback
from Houston I like him he's a good
player obviously incredibly productive
he had he had a Target that helped make
it very productive but he's someone
that's more athletic than people
probably give him credit before you see
him there running away from from the
defense he's a he's someone that can
play and I think he brings this ability
he's a big strong tall guy with a good
arm he's pretty accurate as well and
obviously was a captain for that
football team uh they went out and they
got the job done yeah so after after
Henry hooker came off the board you know
after the first five QBs were gone this
was the most physically gifted guy
available it's six two two twenty see
four six four they he was a legitimate
rushing threat in that Houston offense
and he's got a big arm an NFL caliber
arm right up there probably just just
right behind guys like will Levis and
Anthony Richard in this draft class he
can really spin it to every level of the
football field and
productive you know 4 000 yards 40
touchdowns this past year
has been playing a ton of football four
years as a starter there at Houston
I do though worry he is watching him
makes you nervous with how his feet
patter in the pocket I mean he is a guy
who's just kind of on edge a lot he
really leaned on tankdale on his
separation ability in that offense it
was kind of Tanked out or I scramble and
get outside the pocket and try to create
something he's gonna have to play more
in structure learn how to kind of the
fundamentals of quarterback a little bit
more but this is the kind of again like
his tools at the quarterback position
often go a lot higher and if he was
doing what he did at a bigger school he
would not have lasted this long that's
true and he's I love to watch him play
like watching Houston play was always a
trade it I will say this I felt like
they did not like Dana hooks in that
much at times watching guys come off the
field and he'd be clapping and they just
go walk around him I was like goodness
this seems dysfunctional but he still
there as their head coach he's got a
couple guys get drafted already he's
going to put those on you know they're
gonna go all that's going to go on the
recruiting material try to get some more
guys there okay we got another one
oh DTR the QB run is repeal right now
to the Browns at 140. okay interesting
that is you know what this is this is a
this is a complimentary scheme pick
and I like that for them because this
means instead of trying to play
Kellerman Josh Dobbs who I just think I
think the windows closed on I don't
think the window ever opened on mod I
think the window's closed on top now you
can have a guy that still can fit you
complimentary to watching you don't have
to change your office so often so often
we it looks like they just picked up
pieces to try to like make play some
complimentary football instead of
getting a guy that can actually play
that complimentary football had real
success at the next level I think DTR
got better every year every year got
more trust from his coaches every year
got the ability to not run check with me
we saw him call plays we saw him audible
we saw him get people lined up in the
right position and to me that's high
high value that is also high IQ football
and to me I just really love to see a
guy grow grow grow grow grow and keep
getting better every year not Peak as a
sophomore peek as a freshman the more
take they got in him the better he got
instead of well they got more tape on me
so I couldn't couldn't really do this no
the more tape they got him guess what I
get better every year 48 starts in his
career and experience matters a lot at
the quarterback yes that's like why guys
like Brock Purdy can hit the ground
running because he's a four-year starter
utr is a four-year starter at the
position first as you mentioned every
single year he got better and he's a guy
who you think four five six 646 rushing
yards last year oh he's he's a runner no
this guy ran out of when it was
necessary not first read it's not there
I'm going as well he is a guy who is a
pocket Pastor who has rushing ability
that's why you know Chris Sims had him
in his fourth overall quarterback I'm a
little lower on him than that because I
think the accuracy is still a fairly big
problem for me and that long release I
do not love but he went to the combine
and had the fastest ball speed there
throwing of Andy quarterback in
attendance he has real high-end NFL arm
Talent this is there's a reason why a
lot of quarterbacks are coming off the
boards because this was a good class for
developmental type of guys at that
position outside of even the top end
guys see that's the thing I I love that
about him and I I saw it at the opening
when we were there he's in high school
yeah at the opening watching him drop
back and I know the release is a little
bit loopy but when that ball comes out
of a hand his hand it sings like you can
hear like like it's going and that's why
he's able to make some of these throws
that people might think he's late on I'm
not late I throw the ball hard like this
is what I'm doing and so
it it took him a while to harness it but
it took him good coaching Chip Kelly
took him good development him working on
himself but also working with
quarterbacks coaches and he harnessed
all those all those skills and all those
tools and I'm glad you mentioned
experience because when he got to
college he didn't have it he only played
one year he only started one year of
high school football he played wide
receiver for three years because Tate
Martell was in front of him obviously I
don't know where Tate Martell is but the
reality is he played behind Tate Martell
then he got it to start one year at
Bishop Gorman then he went to play but
he got listen he got full ride
scholarships when he was a wide receiver
he got him at quarterback from people
seeing him as a backup in those games
where Gordon was blowing people out but
he didn't have much experience coming in
so he struggled early and then he got
better and then he got better and now
we're in year four where drug war coming
out of year four and he's a very good
quarterback super talented has the
ability to make every throw that you
want and again I'm glad you mentioned he
didn't run this this is not it their
yardage may be close to the same this is
not the same as Anthony Richardson
running yes this is not the same most of
these are not design runs and most of
these are not I don't like what I don't
know what I'm doing runs these are check
check okay covered covered covered okay
I'll buy myself some more time okay
that's okay nope you know what they're
giving me space over here I'm gonna go
take this first down and I'm gonna get
out of bounds
I uh I love what the Browns have done I
have to say it they did it again to come
in with no first or second round pick to
get the guys that they've gotten so far
that can you know multiple guys that can
actually play a role we've got to trade
Vikings are on the clock now
who we traded for gosh this pick went
Vegas to Indy to Minnesota
the amount of movement at this point in
the draft I I truly like I can't
remember this much movement Vegas
every pick is an absolute
just has no value to anyone apparently
no
and then other picks so they seem to
have so much value to people oh my God
I'm looking down the board pick 159
right now has already been traded four
times
it might get traded again it's where the
Packers are picking next oh that's
incredible
it's when the NFL said you could start
was it three years ago and they said you
could start trading the compensatory
picks that's when the floodgates just
opened they're like oh yeah great
I hardly even want these
now what you do combat story picks or
Dutch
oh she doesn't care about that
yeah it's gonna be interesting I think
that what do we look what are the
Vikings looking at here
let me recap the Vikings draft I got it
where you're right here Minnesota
they drafted the first the first thing
they did was pick up so they they got
Jordan Adams Jordan Madison Blackman and
Jay Ward so they went hey Kirk here's
our second option we needed it Justin
you can't just put everything on him
like we need to give him some help and
then it was hey our defense was
disgusting last year and not in a good
way in the worst way and Brian Flores
got two who do you want yeah you know
who who is fit in your scheme here that
to me is what Makai Blackman and Jay
Ward are
even if the value
oh this is I I like his tape and he's
another guy where at this point in the
draft he's young he is a true Junior
coming out I thought he was truthfully
though better as a sophomore than a
junior but kind of kind of guy who ticks
every box that you want from a defensive
tackle he's six foot three 305 pounds
long arms six eight wingspan
and played solid I don't think like
we're gonna show a highlight reel here
there's really not a lot of highlights
on his tape he's not a guy who was
looking to make plays unfortunately he
was a guy who was looking to execute his
assignment and I thought he did it
really well and I think for a guy who's
young still again true Jr coming out
he's strong he did 30 bench press reps
so he's kind of
you know a lot of the DTs I'm saying not
a lot of pass rushing upside it's not
going to happen but but defensive tackle
is becoming a run first position for a
lot of defenses and this is a guy that I
feel very confident in that regard at
the next level so BJ Hill is the comp
there BJ Hill's obviously been was a
mid-round pick that the Giants and
Bengals were happy as hell with I think
that could be the similar guy for them
yeah I think the fact that he he can't
stuff the Run yeah he does what's that
he answers the he answers the he
understands the assignment he listen
don't you he doesn't get moved goes
that's the face mask but still
[Laughter]
and he showed that he can move a little
bit laterally too which is what you need
to see out of him I think he's a good
player I think they're getting someone
especially with this value 100 pick 142.
he he's he provides quality depth and
he's going to continue to grow into that
role and they need DTS on that roster do
you think he's a zero do you think he
plays more of a three I think he's
versatile enough to just be in any like
us if you want to play sides you know he
left defense tackle versus right defense
tackle I think you can go from one all
the way out to five and not look out of
place so that's the only one that kind
of Versatility that kind of Versatility
is is important they obviously added
Harrison Phillips
um to that defense that's not enough
though you got more needs along that
defensive interior so this is a guy that
could be playing real snaps year one for
you
good miss all right we're cooking
it's a coil and Roy so to recap where we
are right now the Browns have a pick
that's in we're waiting on that one but
we just had Jacqueline Roy Dorian
Thompson Robinson he goes to the Browns
the Browns had the Browns got DTR and
they have a pick right now so that's
pretty fun Clayton toon was good to the
Cardinals Darius rushed to the Colts KJ
Henry to the commanders and Yasir
Abdullah to the Jaguars
we got 20. Cameron Hicks you see this is
the draft in my opinion like that's that
is
those are four guys at least the first
four that can be starters you didn't
have a first second round pick and those
are four guys in my opinion that will in
Time start for your football team that's
oh that's good drafting that that is a
that's a necessary draft too for the
Cleveland Browns because last year did
not go their way
that was a pretty premium pick
the pick is in a little Northwestern
cornerback Cameron Mitchells is the pick
here another pick for the Cleveland
Browns they go defense again they get
some more defense they're getting some
help this is a really interesting pick
for them because they they look they're
they're looking to fix a lot of
different things
former teammates of their first round
pick a couple years ago Greg Newsom the
second at Northwestern this guy had some
fans I know he was on a number of top
hundred boards that I saw I think he's a
little a question is play strength you
know 511 191 he could get pushed around
a touch but he's Twitchy this guy can
really mirror a route tree we're in a
447 4.06 short shuttle 6893 cone like
ticking those boxes
10 pass breakups this past season I I
think he's a solid all-around corner I
think he could play slot or outside if
need be may not have super high end to
his game it may have never been a
lockdown guy there at Northwestern but I
think versatile enough that you know you
have your starters in place there you
have Denzel Ward you have Martin Emerson
you have Greg Newsom you don't need a
starter for you you need a guy to wear
if my slot gets hurt someone can play
slot if my outside corner gets hurt
someone could play outside this is a guy
that can do both
oh a body conda comes off the board
Israel body conda running back from pitt
this guy is an absolute Warrior like
this watch the way he runs watch how
fast he is suddenness there's a
suddenness to his game that I really
enjoy the the it takes him two steps to
get the top speed he may not have the
highest top end speed but he does have
burst and that burst is what gets you
into space the burst gets you into space
you get into space now it's a foot race
he might not win every foot race but at
least he has the burst to get into space
you see that little angle right there
breaks a tackle side steps to tackle
your arms aren't on me and he's gonna
try to get to the end zone look at that
he's a unique Prospect for a number of
reasons one he's the youngest Prospect
in this tracklist okay he does not turn
21 until October so super you
1431 yards this last year and like he
was the biggest big play running back in
the class it was it was all or nothing
for him he had a ton of runs of 40 plus
yards this past season and once he got
in the open field see ya it was lights
out he was taking to the house I do
though why he falls this point in the
draft
never been too much as a wide receiver
sure and running style wise I just did
not like his tape and now he's young
fairly inexperienced that can improve
but to me he looked like how running
backs excuse me how wide receivers look
when they have to get placed at running
back where it's like the pacing is not
correct the vision is not worth taking
you where it's supposed to go and the
feet don't always uh churn into contact
he'll stop his feet in the backfield a
little too often for my money but if you
can coach him up if you can get him with
a good running back coach they can get
in his ear and really get him to work on
his fundamentals this is as physically
gifted a running back that exists in
this draft class in terms of pure
explosiveness and size 216 pounds
running a 444 with a 41 inch vertical
this guy can hook he's just very very
rough around the edges Rough Around the
Edges but that game we just saw right
there the Virginia Tech game he went for
320 yards oh yeah 320 yards in that game
let me redo these 71 runs for first down
38 runs of over 10 yards and 16 runs of
over 20 yards like who he is this is
this season like he gets the job done I
really love watching him play uh for
those pit Panthers let's see what else
we got
him and Brisa I mean yeah I actually
really like uh who's the Jets are their
back that was playing at the end of last
year Donovan Knight I like their
backfield now yeah they have Bam Bam Bam
Knight Michael Carter Brees Hall and
this guy so you have two you know
high-end explosive dudes you have one
great pass catcher and Michael Carter
and you have an elusive kind of between
the tackles back in bam Knight that
you're really never getting a drop off
uh in this I mean obviously Breeze is
obviously the cream of the crop in that
battlefield but in a certain role you
have guys that can fill it
there we go
oh Antonio Mafi Antonio Mafi from UCLA
another UCLA alignment off the board Ah
that's in listen they're far they're
realizing oh there was a reason why Zack
Chardonnay was so productive so this is
a good pick man where do you think he
plays at the next level this dude is a
guard through and through he is so both
of their guards coming off the board
yeah six foot three 329 he started his
career and was playing legit snaps as a
freshman sophomore started 14 games
those two years as a nose tackle for
UCLA
switches to offensive line in 2020
during the pandemic doesn't play any
that year
gets his feet wet in 2021 and finally
becomes a starter this past season and
his tape for again three years of ever
playing offensive line
I was a fan of that I mean the guy knows
how to use his hands he's powerful as
I mean he can move people as strong
as an office line as you'll see in this
draft class just the feet are not there
he is he is not a high-end you know
mobile agile dude he's going to struggle
to find and locate in space but in a
phone booth like we're talking about
with this Patriots and what they're
doing offensively put him next to
someone like Michael aquanu or just what
they have there Trent Brown and this guy
you are crushing double teams oh you
drafted kalijah can't see and you wanna
you wanna see me run Duo 30 times a game
at you you're not going to be able to
hold up to dudes like this so and that's
that's the goal the goal is listen
everybody everybody else wants to get
small everybody wants to run the spread
everybody wants to do this and everyone
wants to build their defense to stop
that guess what we're going to be
different we're going to be different
we're going to do something different
we're going to go ahead and go out there
and we're going to go out there and
we're gonna Maul you Maul you we're
going to grind you into dust I can't
like this is good it's gonna be fun to
watch kind of that old school going back
to the old school style where it's just
you know not not quite three yards in a
cloud of dust but if we have to Hulk up
we will it's
interesting team building draft for the
Patriots kind of giving you Insight in
what they want to do all right they like
their draft though so we got this we got
a recap here guys we got KJ Henry he's
going to the commanders Edge rusher out
of Clemson we got Darius Rush Corner out
of South Carolina he's going to the
Colts we got Clayton tune Houston
quarterback going to the Cardinals
giving them a little bit of insurance uh
Cleveland Browns you get more insurance
as well with QB DTR during times at
Robinson out of UCLA at the Vikings we
have jaqualin Roy a defensive lineman
out of LSU a guy that's going to be a
tough run stopper next up we've got the
Browns again taking a cornerback Cameron
Mitchell this time from Northwestern the
Jets have the Jets take Israel I've been
in conda from Pitt and then the Patriots
take Antonio Mafi this is gonna this is
interesting now we got the Carolina
Panthers coming up and we're going to
see what they do in this draft a lot of
picks I like there yeah there's no pick
there that I'm like what do you thinking
I don't know I mean I mean we're in the
fifth round too so so even if it was a
pick where I was like I gotta get a fake
udfa grade on them we're 100 picks we're
close to getting to udfa anyway so can't
complain too much but a lot of guys that
I think
you know fifth rounders sometimes you
draft them and then you never hear about
them again a lot of guys I think and
another one here coming off the
board here we go I know this one and
Jamie Robinson that this guy can start
this is a starting safety in the NFL
right there for you he was a four-year
starter between two years in South
Carolina two years at Florida State
played slot has played deep has played
in the Box one of the best tacklers in
this draft class consistently just
doesn't have
the physical profile and so at this
point the draft I'm either targeting
high-end athletes who like I said good
athletes with good excuses or middling
athletes with high-end production this
to me is a middling athlete with
high-end production he was as impactful
as any safety you watch him tackle there
yeah oh I'm a big fan he's a top 75
player for me this was a guy on my board
yeah he's he is
he's great coming downhill
he's a violent football player and
listen I want violence out of my safety
I need you to be violent I want you to
be violent I need that violence to show
you so show people like listen you don't
want to catch the ball back here and I
know the game's changed and the rules
have changed but listen you hit somebody
in their kidneys guess what they don't
want they don't want to go they don't
want to go across the middle either so
that's the way I look at it like that
violence is important so this is pretty
cool obviously a kid that played at
South Carolina
then goes to Florida State
being part of the kind of Florida
State's kind of mini Resurgence was
getting better on defense I'm excited
for uh what's his name
for next year's defense the defensive
end they've got down there too oh Jerry
verse surprisingly didn't come out yeah
I was that's what I was gonna say I was
surprised to see Jared verse surprised
he didn't come out so that's a big thing
for them this upcoming season so I'll
say this so to put some contacts to
Robinson's you know lack of traits like
I was saying so he's five foot ten 191.
he has only a six foot wingspan it's
only 29 to five Ace inch arms so short
arms undersized a little bit and only
ran a four five nine but man flip on the
tape and it's like
do I do I mine that much like he's not
going to be a pure deep safety he's
probably going to be a two-high guy also
like ideally is where I'm looking at him
but a guy with like slot versatility
that
you know maybe the traits don't say he
can do a lot of things he does but he
tells a different story especially
because he knows what he's doing that's
the other part of it that's the thing
we've talked a little bit about it but
anticipation can help you get places you
probably shouldn't even be and that's
what that's what works for a guy like
him understanding what's going on around
you on the field knowing where you're
supposed to be and then getting there
I'll say this 23 bench press reps though
for safety that's big boy stuff well
guess what you got short arms yeah yeah
that helps though
that's my excuse my long arm that's why
I can't hit 225 anymore dude I haven't
even tried are you kidding me I have not
even tried uh oh my goodness all right
we gotta pick in let's see does anybody
know who it is
everybody's not talking about it got it
who we got we got the Saints on the
Titans got their pick in and then I need
the Packers to draft someone high in my
bore
look at that I'm excited all right whose
tops a veil here dude Luke wittler still
hasn't come off the board that one's
poof yeah I know that's some there's got
to be something dude if he's on the
board for the Titans they gotta pull the
trigger right that that has to be if the
Titans don't I will be floored okay
let's look at the big board Luke
whippler's still there Tana McKee is
still there Travis Hodges Tomlinson is
still there
Antonio Johnson's still there Andre
Carter a guy wanted to talk about but
now that we look at where we are we may
not get to talk about him so we might
have to just do it anyway so
um A.T Perry I love him Dwayne McBride
love him too uh Corey Trice we've
already talked about uh more of a
journal what do you think about him so
jomo's the guy who had a real good
breakout season this past year he's long
he's linearly explosive and he's a fifth
year dude who's only 21 years old he got
to Texas at 17 years old oh man and he
has improved year on year ever since uh
he's one that you know not many guys
that I think profile to like above
average starters at this point in the
draft he's the one that I could see
doing that because he has so much room
to grow the top player on the consensus
board right now I'm just like the pro
football network says Antonio Johnson
64th player he's a big surprise to still
be available at this point in the draft
oof Jordan Howden yep gotta be honest
haven't washed them
first guy 147 first guy I got to that is
not uh in the microwave
ah look at that yeah don't have a ton on
him either I watch but here's the thing
I did watch Minnesota play I knew their
secondary was good their secondary has
been good it comes with the same thing
we talked about with Illinois same thing
we talked about with Maryland he so well
let's look what he brings to the table
let's check out and check it out
okay five eleven 203. yeah 32 and a
quarter inch arms he had a 39.5 inch
vertical as protein ran four four nine
so we go from a guy who's a production
dude in in Jamie Robinson weigh traits
too and Jordan Howard and they had
another trade seat safety there who went
blanking on his name in Minnesota who am
I thinking up there that's fascinating
or something but they had a good
defensive backfield him Terrell Smith is
probably going to come off the board
here sometime soon in the Minnesota
corner so they had a real secondary this
past season how no
look at the Saints what they've done
they've added Jordan Howard and they've
got Jake hayner Nick saldivari
Kendra Miller Isaiah foskey Brian
bressey 1-2
three defensive guys and three offensive
guys there we go yeah
here we go they're they're secondary now
safeties they already obviously have
Tyler Matthew Marcus may as your
starters but after that it gets a little
thin yeah JC gray Jonathan Abram and
smoke Monday so safety as far as team
that you know I think tight end might be
your only quote unquote need on this
roster at the moment with all the picks
that they've made so far
you're looking for hounds you know
special teams depth and safety position
where if one of those first two guys got
hurt you probably would not feel great
about who was coming in after them
there we go we got another pick in this
is for the Titans let's see what they
did here dude and this if if they get
Luke whippler
that would be amazing this will be one
of my favorite drafts you know going
grebel's there
Ohio State and he reminds me of like Ben
Jones you know like that's the kind of
Center the guy who was like stalwart
there for forever
as stretch Zone type of Center that's
what they do so bread and butter my Lord
run the card in
come on go ahead and do it
I'm looking so Bears after this Packers
after that the Bears draft has been
interesting to say the least yeah but
we've got to be talking about it how
it's like a bunch of Boomer boss type of
dudes yep that they've gone with I
wouldn't hate if they kind of went a
little bit safer here and try to get a
guy like a Moro Jama who can just like
see the football field for you can be a
little consistent for you
Josh Weil from Cincy
that's who the pick is
for the Tennessee Titans
this is Josh Wilde from Cincinnati this
is a guy Cincinnati has had a couple of
really good tight ends obviously most
notably is Travis Kelsey but they've had
some other good Titans as well when you
look at Josh wow I think he does one of
those things that all their tight ends
have done that most of the wide
receivers are doing especially the
taller ones they catch the ball well in
that High Point situation they High
Point the ball well they don't always
get a ton of Separation but when they
catch the football it's up high and they
go they go out and they make plays so
this is one that for me he could save
your quarterback be wide open and come
back to him to make some play so when I
look at him I see someone that's not
afraid of traffic look at him lined up
in the backfield okay there's a little
bit of Versatility this is going to be
an interesting interesting fit for them
because I don't know that he's going to
be like the blocker that they need to
get yeah I agree it's tough with this
thin as this look at him yeah he's
skinny and short arms so he's he's one
of the few guys who is taller than his
wingspan six foot six with a six foot
five inch wingspan that rarely happens
but he's got really good ball skills
he's really reliable he can get up the
seam a different type of tight end than
Chicago who you got in the roster who's
more of your move space throme screens
get them Yak stuff I think Wiley can
actually like work down field make plays
outside his frame even if you know maybe
he has short arms to do so so he he's
kind of just a death tight end I
profiled him as a number two type of
tight end for the next level had him a
little lower down on my board because of
that
you play volleyball is that him or is
that a different player
I am not sure about that one yeah I know
Cincinnati had yeah it's not him it was
the guy it was nope that was him and
volleyball player
I mean six six dude if you're not
playing volleyball at six six you're
missing out it is it does suck when you
play volleyball like ever you go like
play beach volleyball and there's like a
guy who's good and like his ball and
you're like okay it could have been the
receiver that came out last year
that was fierce Pierce feels like he'd
be a volleyball player yeah I think I
think that dude could jump
if I could still jump yes so where are
we at we got a Seoul
to the Bears Noah sold to the bears oh I
like that pick yeah that's great that's
absolutely fantastic yeah Sewells
his unique dude in that he's never gonna
be a coverage off ball linebacker no he
is 250 pounds sure six foot one he he is
he is like penne Sewell condensed down
right you know like you just squish him
down and that's Noah Sewell
powerful dude he did 27 bench press reps
and he's only a true Junior coming out
here
you're getting a downhill football
player I truthfully I said move him to
Edge he has almost the same body type as
Micah Parsons the guy who was sitting
here next to us a couple days ago in
that you know undersized but he plays
with such good leverage he plays with
such power and he uses hand so violently
that I think he can Rush the pastor if
I'm the Bears that's probably where I'm
starting them out just because I know as
an off ball linebacker you're not
getting the agility you're not getting
the sort of range you want in coverage
to be making plays to where I think
there's still a spot for him on a
football field but I just don't think
it's where he played at at Oregon yeah I
think the interesting part about him is
the the course correction with how he's
incred he over pursues then he course
corrects and he it's one of those things
that he is a violent football player and
I mean that's going to be probably next
year's best tight end and he just
decided to move him out of the way so I
look at this and I just think that he's
you get stuck a little bit as you
mentioned with moving laterally can you
move into I wonder what he looks like
playing on the edge like a true Edge
coming downhill to make make the rush
because I think he's probably a little
bit more I don't think he's as athletic
as as Parcels oh no no yeah but no one
is right but I think he can make plays I
think there's a violence in him
that not many other guys yes and that's
something that you can't teach that and
you look at the Bears depth or they have
TJ Edwards
Trey Edmonds and Jack Sanborn at those
that three linebacker spot so they got
options now at linebacker that's why
this to me feels like they don't have a
lot of options at Edge I'd be surprised
if he's not moved there it's gonna be
interesting
Packers who we got
Sean Clifford are you me
no way
Sean Clifford
I don't want to hate on him too much
because he's already gotten that from
every Penn State fan in existence but
like
John Clifford
I don't know you gotta break it down
we don't need to let's move on I can't
believe her
over Tanner McKee I like Sean Clifford I
think they're at the same Elite 11. hey
man Tanner McKee I think so yeah instead
of five years ago he is um he's the guys
had a long Winding Road and
he did what he could for Penn State I
just think I think that obviously he had
a rough go over at Penn State obviously
there was some injury situation but also
he's a guy that he's got to figure out
who he is and what he does and I think
that going there he doesn't he doesn't
put the put his feet to the fire he
doesn't put Jordan left's feet to the
fire no but he does provide a guy who
knows how to play the quarterback spot
he's never going to be your saver but
this is going to be interesting yeah I I
had a udfa grade I I was not
particularly impressed by his tape but I
will say he got better he's got better
went on he he did improve this past
season it was his best year
it was still not draftable and he is uh
going to be 25 by the time the season
starts yep
so
huh
yeah I mean that's the point of the
draft we're at though right yeah is that
right
this Sean Clifford doesn't even have to
see an FL roster and no no like right
you don't expect this you don't expect
him to yeah you don't expect any of
these guys to but that's I'm still
surprised because I think there are some
guys that still are capable of making
him playing NFL roster so
there we go Packers current draft Sean
clear add Sean Clifford to Colby wooden
Tucker craft Jaden Reed Luke Musgrave
and Lucas Van Ness got two loops on
there an interesting draft to say the
least really all over the map I I think
though once you get uh
Lucas van s Luke Musgrave talk craft I
think that's I think those are good
players I think those are impact type of
guys I'm very curious you don't draft
tight ends where they drafted them
early second early third right without a
plan
right to revamp your offensive plan
you're not just saying oh there's going
to be a tight end competition one of you
is going to start you're saying you guys
are both going to see the football field
at some time right like when the
Patriots drafted Aaron Hernandez after
Rob Gronkowski right there was a plan in
place I wonder if what that's going to
look like
oh Justin shorter interesting oh wow
look at this Justin shorter this guy's
kind of been around the block right
Penn State to Oregon to Florida he is
someone again who I saw at the opening
Justin shorter I mean he reminds me of
like he's a true possession receiver he
has he's been he played a lot of
football I think that there's a chance
that he not only could he make a rusher
I think he's going to be some sort of a
leader for somebody because he's been
everywhere he's played with everybody he
knows what he's doing he's got a lot of
skills there was a time
when Penn State could have had Justin
Fields throwing to adjusted shorter I I
saw them throwing to each other and both
and then Fields obviously famously ends
up at Georgia then goes to Ohio State
shorter gets to Penn State then heads
off to Oregon then gets his goes kick
goes on down to Florida this is an
interesting pick this is a guy that for
me when I went there and was doing some
of those comps you guys always like let
me pull them up Justin shorter I I said
Alvin Harper like oh man he's not going
to be your number one or two he's not
gonna be aware too but you know what
he's gonna be okay yeah if you need him
in a pinch he's going to do something
that you didn't expect and that's going
to be that's what he's gonna need to do
he truthfully there were a few guys in
this class that I said watching the tape
I'm like why not add 20 pounds and try
to call yourself tight end yeah here's
one of them he's six foot four 234
pounds at his pro day so he's you know a
Popeye's meal from qualifying his
Titanic six foot ten six foot ten inch
wingspan really reliable hands I mean I
think he only had a couple drops over
his entire collegiate career now also
didn't have a ton of catches over his
collegiate career peaked with 577 yards
this past season just no dynamism to him
no suddenness no separation ability he
is a guy who you're throwing jump balls
to to try to get production out of them
Mike Morris coming off the board here
the Michigan Edge rusher and now on tape
he was better than the 151st best player
in this draft class he's six foot six in
the 270 pound range 275 is what he
weighed in at the combine and he uses
handswell he knows how to rush the
passer he Paces his rushes really well
he just is a very very limited athlete
listed at Michigan at 290 I thought
that's kind of the player I thought you
were getting maybe like a four or five
technique but the 275 is really not in
that range of what you want I think he's
a pure Edge but dude is just stiff 465
short shuttle 7463 cone
5.08 40 at his Pro Day those are not
good numbers
um and when he doesn't jump the snap
like right there he really does not test
the edge for offensive tackles and so
good tape but a poor poor athlete by NFL
standards yeah but I think the question
is can he jump the snap and that's it
that's that's a that's a hard thing to
tell because some some guys are really
good at it in college and then they
can't do it at the next level other guys
learn it at the next level some guys
never learn it yeah and so that's going
to be the interesting part of all this
and again we're getting them in the
fifth round I did look it up shorter no
Oregon just just pick state to Florida
yeah but it's fine he is listen you go
back to Mike Morris
he has to in terms of what the Seahawks
are getting look at this look at this
draft defense offense defense offense
offense defense defense they know what
they're doing they want to get big up
front
Anthony Bradford's going to help them do
that Zach charbonnet is going to help
him with that they also want to stretch
you Jackson Smith and jig was going to
help them do that you throw in Devin
Witherspoon Derek Hall Mike Morris they
have the opportunity and then Cameron
young obviously they have the
opportunity to go out there and
absolutely put their hands on people
yeah Seahawks they're in a spot to
really take control of the West it is up
for grass that's what I was going to say
it's up for grabs the Cardinals I have a
quarterback coming off an injury and
they stinks the Rams yeah have to
basically completely rebuild the roster
yeah
okay the 49ers obviously rolling with
Brock after a UCL tear I have no idea
Colby sourceful
excuse me
who
Cobra Source doll William Mary did not
get to my William and Mary tape this
year that was on the back burner I I
couldn't tell you who this is yeah there
we go unfortunately yeah sorry guys
um no um I don't have the resources of
an NFL front office at my disposal the
way that you guys these guys do but he
is six foot five 305 pounds ran a five
one five forty at his pro day and four
seven short shuttle those are solid
numbers 33 inch arms so
maybe you could stick that tackle I
don't know
who do you go to there he went to the
Lions all right yep
culture fit I'm looking at his picture
right now long flowing locks
that's got Dan Campbell's name written
all over look at that
all right
49ers that's the other team we were
thinking of since the 40 it's about them
in the 49ers
and the 49ers are just they're in a
weird spot of quarterback where you you
Trey Lance you have no clue what you're
having them yep and your guy who was
good as a rookie is coming off probably
the worst injury you can have for a
quarterback in a in an elbow
tear so we shall see so the Seahawks are
in it I think it's the reason why they
didn't go quarterback when they're
sitting at pick five and could have
because they want to get involved right
now they've made the playoffs when
people no one in thought they were no
one thought they had a chance made the
playoffs and now are in a prime driver
seat to add more talent to this roster
and I think just keep pushing so I think
that's I think looking at everything in
his own individual scenario instead of
looking at
what who who picked who or who picked
what I think it's important to realize
they view they view themselves as having
a window so they went and got things
that could help them right now
instead of well how's this guy going to
help why didn't we get this guy he's we
could develop him no you don't they
don't they're not looking for
development they're looking for guys
that can play right now go out there
make plays and do what they need to do
you see as talented as some of the other
guys are maybe still on the board no
but you know what he's going to be able
to do get into that meeting understand
what's going on and be able to translate
that meaning work to field work and help
them win football games right now to
hopefully get to the playoffs but also
get to the Super Bowl yeah
and the NFC you got
Eagles obviously going to be your
returning favorites Cowboys
then who and hell like then then who are
you afraid of after those two that
wasn't Eagles you said yeah
no the West yeah rock pretty LED
49ers scared like the the Seahawks if
they if they make some strides here and
they hit on these rookies quick
they could be that 13 in the in the NFC
oh the dentist kid from Pitt
oh Slovakia yeah
dude's got a unique build yes very long
arms long arms linebacker yeah Slovakia
uh Slovakia Dennis from pitt he's got
long arms this is the guy that probably
he he see he that and I guess I see the
difference between Noah soul in him yeah
because he can move well laterally he
understands what's going on in front of
him and the thing about Dennis is he he
still can makes himself kind of small
and come through the hole and create
penetration and listen playing for you
can't play for Pat and arduzy you
specifically can't play linebacker for
Pat narduzzi if you're not willing to
stick your nose in there and that's
something he's willing to do this is a
tough dude man I'm a fan of the way this
guy plays the game of football four six
three forty he went 41.5 inch in the
vertical he's an explosive athlete now
in coverage at the Senior Bowl nothing
special I I didn't think he was he was
the guy who makes plays like this in
front of him but if he has to turn and
run if he has to react laterally
you're meh like but you can survive with
him at linebacker he's not a liability
by any means in coverage and the guy who
we're talking about going to tide bowls
and his defense he's going to be asked
to come down hill and Blitz he can do
that so I'm a fan of this pick at where
it came off the board
oh and then Olu oluwatini coming off the
board to the Seahawks oh wow here that's
the guy who
they probably need a center if there's
any position on this interior that they
could use it probably is the center
position for the Seahawks and I think
he's NFL ready now is he NFL ready and
you know quality starter probably not I
don't think he's that as an athlete I
think his ability to sustain blocks I
question but he is tough he is physical
and he's obviously experienced sixth
year guy coming out multiple years I
think five years in Virginia then
transfers to Michigan this past season
they obviously win the Joe Moore Awards
the best offense line in the country and
I thought he was their best offensive
lineman but I just think a little bit of
a limited dude but also a guy that could
probably start for you right away well
our guard's still on the board Luke whip
yeah no but so the Seahawks and what
they want to do they do big powerful
super strong that's what they've kind of
targeted over the years especially on
the interior two completely different
types of offensive alignment whippler is
a stretch Zone pull to the edge get to
the second level although itemi is your
I can handle NFL caliber nose tackles
one-on-one sort of guy yeah you're like
I like to see it man he he I liked
watching them play because they were so
strong up front up until they weren't
when yeah yeah so kill yourself yeah saw
Georgia or no excuse me
well George the year before that George
of the year before that but he wasn't he
wasn't there that year yeah yeah so yeah
but you look at him he can move bodies
and I see that's a great part of it if
you can move those bodies and keep
running I love the effort there to try
to keep running down the play that's
good here you see him catch hold he
holds his line even though the rest of
those guys give up some space and put
create pressure for the quarterback this
is a big score and play for them against
Ohio State he held his own against Ohio
State you got that's what you have to do
to be in the position here to have a
team like this like the Seattle Seahawks
want to take you can we
okay let's look at the big board Travis
Hodges the first three haven't changed
in a while in a long time yeah Antonio
Johnson's on there as well Andre Carter
is on there uh we got Dwayne McBride I
really like him I like he's got to come
off the board here sometimes right he's
too talented yeah so we've got all these
guys on the board we're waiting to see
who the 49ers pick
I would love Corey Trice here truthfully
if they're you know they kind of farted
out whatever that was in the third round
with those picks drafting the kicker but
they could get a guy in Cory Trice that
like can actually
make an impact on this roster and like
fits what they want to do defensively
um I would love if that's the pick we'll
see
come on show me
so let's reset the 49ers here who have
they gotten so far
so they went jair Brown they traded up
for him then they went Jake Moody the
kicker Championship level kicker
probably Cameron lato tight end we
discussed that one yep we did and then
that was their last pick they had those
three at the back end of the third and
now they're on the clock for the first
time since then so three guys there
where I was like Shire Brown I like but
it's like no one really make an impact
now maybe they go
foreign
he's very good playing impressed man he
gets hands on he tracks the ball well
obviously it's a bad throw but you know
what a lot of cornerbacks create they
they commit pass interference on that
play because they can't get their head
around so that's a great play Daryl
luter from South Alabama the Jaguars I
love this kid is good he can really play
did you have him higher than this or no
no this is right at the range I had him
but I was a fan uh of his tape I just
think a little limited athletically I
didn't see quite the feet and footwork
that it takes to be like kind of a
high-end corner but I think he can start
in the league and you can be an average
starter in time because of the way he
plays you know he wants to play
aggressive he wants to attack the
football in the air he can attack the
football in the air five picks the past
two years 22 pass breakups the past two
seasons and he's got long arms so just
kind of a meh athlete by NFL standards
but play style wise he has what it takes
to transfer from a low level competition
in South Alabama to a high level
competition obviously in the NFC West so
a guy that fits again kind of what this
the uh the 49ers want to do defensively
they are now obviously without tobacco
Ryan's I mean they've got the Amador
Lenore
funga
to Sean Gibson
Jarvis Ward
and Miles Hartsfield as their first five
and Lenore Ambry Thomas wow I didn't
realize he was with the 49ers the more
Lenore excuse me Thomas and hufango
we're all guys they find late in this
sort of range of the draft so
not crazy I I don't how do you feel
about this pick Jordan McFadden the
offered the guard from Clemson I like
Jordan McFadden you like him I don't I
question his place during being honest I
do because watching Clemson's offensive
line over the last
but essentially since Trevor Lawrence
left watching that offensive line has
been
pretty appalling
um the way that they've been able to be
pushed around by teams they get pushed
around I'll never forget was it the
Georgia game I believe
where they they were in the back they
were they were lined up at the three and
the whole offensive line ended up in the
end zone and I was like how does this
happen I wasn't going backwards into the
end zone I didn't I didn't get it like I
don't I don't understand how that
happened so I just questioned his play
strength I think he has the size I think
he has the tangibles they say he wins he
won the Jacobs blocking trophy I still
am just watching him I just wonder
a lot a lot of The Blocking that that
that team does is shielding and creating
increases so that they can the running
back can create the whole not bruise
it's not like playing at Arkansas it's
not playing in Georgia or Alabama no I
do question this place rank too I think
he may even be like a center convert
he's six foot two 300 pounds three year
starter though attack all four Clemson
first year at right tackle two years at
left tackle
long arms though he still has 34 inch
arms obviously at six foot two now a lot
of people are going to give you a shot
at tackle though so he's probably
kicking inside but I love his technique
I love the way he uses his hands he just
has balance issues and he just has play
strength issues he's just not going to
move people he's going to have to
sustain blocks
um more than he you know imposes his
will on other guys so that's how I see
him as a process we are all on the same
page on that one yeah ukai blue
I don't think there's an e at the end of
the second blue there technically in his
name but Kai blue is a one of the better
Zone Corners his ability to move in
space from off and kind of reduce space
as you see here and kind of get into
creating wide receivers I'm a fan of
eliminate separation not a pure press
guy not a pure man guy but you know
Baltimore there they just like to load
up on versatile Corners I think he's a
guy that I'd be comfortable even moving
to safety if you wanted him to and so
they needed it obviously they've kind of
gotten depleted in the past couple
seasons and this is a guy that a lot of
people had a lot higher I think
consensus board had him as a top hundred
player I had him just outside the top
100 and the 120s but man
he's solid football player look I I was
going to ask you about the safety thing
because I do think he has great ball
skills or the ability to come downhill
and make plays but also the ability to
play in the backing I think he is fast
enough in the back end to go make plays
so this is another let's get him so it's
one of those things where with Kai blue
uh with Kelly he's so
versatile
I don't want him to play Man
consistently yeah I wanted to play man
if you are if this is a if this is an
all-out Blitz and the ball's coming out
quick and he can play it from off
instead of playing it from press gets to
see through and then go make a play I
want that
but I don't want this I if something if
that's the case the exact place where
they come with they come on the blitz
he's playing them off and then he gets
to go break and make a play that's what
I want him to do if he's playing any man
but otherwise I'd like him in deep deep
thirds I like him in cover too uh at the
corner or at the safety spot I think he
could do either one of those yeah and so
they kind of had to move to a more Zone
heavy approach last year simply because
Marcus Peters was not playing man
anymore yeah he was now at the point in
his career where he could do that
consistently and not get torched so I
think they probably are going to because
they really haven't added too much else
to that cornerback group you have Marlon
Humphrey obviously feel great about him
but then you got question marks you got
Jalen armor Davis who drafted the fourth
last year who had some fans item as top
100 player last year but obviously as a
fourth rounder he got kind of torched in
the games he did play yeah Brandon
Stevens who was the third rounder of the
year before that he hasn't shown much
for you Marin Williams who was a fourth
rounder last year as well you got a lot
of question marks obviously haven't
addressed it to date in this this draft
but I think at some point they had to do
it and this is a corner that kind of
fits their versatility that they covet
on the back end
all right who's on the clock the Colts
boom here we go Colts
Colts have been kind of cooking if if
they get back in the lab here and make
another good pick they're in the running
for my favorite draft so far got it oh
is this Daniel Scott is that
let's see
I think it is oh dude yeah he's a player
this is one of not a lot of single High
guys in this class not a lot of guys
with real deal range in this draft class
and he is one of them I think he can
really cook sideline to sideline they
got a guy last year Nick cross who fills
that mold as well but Daniel's got four
four five speed six one 208 and on tape
that 455 shows up he gets there in a
hurry two plays um I do think though he
doesn't necessarily play up to that 208
consistently like I'm not putting him in
the Box a ton but the guys range is real
and and I'm surprised he lasted this
long because as I said there's just not
a lot of athletes in this safety class
um and and I think he could and he can
steal some playing time there over the
course there's a contract for the Colts
yeah so let's see what the Colts have
done so far Anthony Richardson Julius
Prince Josh Downs
Blake Freeland
um
at a ballway at a Bari Darius Rush
that's a corner Daniel Scott that's a
safety so they've went and got they're
working one two three
four four defensive guys three of them
are defensive backs yeah they they know
what they're working to do and Scott is
an interesting guy because he can move
around uh and he will he likes the
trigger and that's a cool thing for him
he's not afraid to listen play for
Justin Wilcox you better not be afraid
like that's one of the things you can
people can joke all around they want
about Cal not being that good or not
caring about football but Wilcox cares
and Wilcox also is very good at coaching
in a second
this is
this is good tape like he's legitimate
like this is this guy can be a star for
you and now safety is a position that
you can find guys for fifth round but
like sure plays like that this is the
fourth round getting over the top of a
vertical from a single high is not not
something
a lot of the safeties that have come off
the board quite frankly can do you know
and so he offers a different skill set
that him and Nick cross if that was your
two starting safeties that's an athletic
Duo on the back end that is pretty
rangey rangy Duo so
I'm not if I'm the Colts I'm a Colts fan
right now I am
this is one of my favorite drafts
truthfully that is a top three draft
that I've seen so far okay of anyone in
the NFL so the Packers are drafting
is it Jacksonville to Atlanta to Detroit
to Green Bay
this was the four traded pick
please just don't trash on Clifford
again
dontavian Wicks oh wide receiver look at
that
contavian get out of Virginia
super productive right yeah very
productive he's kind of I'm not gonna
call him a fallen Gadget guy definitely
looks like he's better out of the slot
but he's super Shifty finds a way to get
into the end zone finds a way to get
open which is important and a bigger
body they obviously love bigger body
wide receivers he's six foot one 205
pounds he had over 1200 yards back in
2021 when Virginia was throwing the ball
all over the yard a little bit of a step
back this year 430 yards and my worry
about them and I can't believe the
Packers keep picking these guys drops
dude nine drops this past year
um 39 catchable over like a 12 drop rate
in his career the Packers obviously
think they can coach hands yeah because
they drafted two high drop rate guys
last year and Christian Watson's and
Romeo Dobbs yep but as a fan I can tell
you it's very frustrating to watch guys
drop footballs and so that is who
donated Wicks is that but he's a guy
who's probably like a you know a number
three I think he's an NFL wide receiver
he's just a little bit Limited does a
four six two forty bother you yeah I
mean it does that's why he's like
limited in the role he's going to play
he's not a downfield threat you have the
downfield threats though in Dobbs and
Watson so you don't necessarily need
another one even if
I would enjoy another one but there's at
this point the draft the wide receiver
class is quite frankly cooked you got
A.T Perry is really the only other one
that I'd go to bat for ever being a
starter in the league right now in this
wide receiver class I like the Wake
forestry but that's I I would not Bank
on any other wide receiver in this class
ending up being a starter
boom there we go
we're at the Jazz with the pick in it
with this this is pick one this is
picked 25 of the fourth of the fifth
round we have 22 picks so 17 more after
this there we go
we're at 160 we're going all the way to
177.
Jaguars draft I will say has been one of
the weirdest drafts we've discussed a
lot of people as being like here's the
theme here's what they're trying to do
here's how these guys fit into their
draft this one's been Anton Harrison's
your backup swing tackle Brenton strange
is a backup tight end tank Bixby is a
backup running back there we go somebody
comes off the big board then Trail
Miller is a backup linebacker
Antonio Johnson but so I cannot believe
they got him here yeah because this was
the position right that everyone kept
mocking them first round everyone's like
they need a slot they need a slot they
need a slot Brian Branch put him in
there when Antonio Johnson was for a lot
of people's money the second best slot
in this class
60th player on the consensus board now I
had him a little bit lower than that but
still I had him as a damn good football
player 64th I think his ability around
the last scrimmage is almost like a poor
man's Kyle Hamilton in what right Paul
Hamilton did from the slot last year
with the Baltimore Ravens I think that's
just what you do that's where you play
attacks a m let them play around the
line of scrimmage he runs a four five
two he can kind of honestly Place
quicker than that in short areas and
he's physical we'll blow up screens this
is a tremendous pick this is Jaguars
after kind of a lot of huh what's the
what's the thought process there at sort
of picks this is a pick that thought
process is obvious the fit's obvious and
the value is as obvious as well I love
it there you go offense offense offense
with Anton Harrison Britain's trans and
tank Bisbee then they go defense defense
defense defense with ventrell Miller
Tyler Lacey uh Yasir Abdullah and then
of course Antonio Johnson just now got
to really good safety really good at
getting downhill really good at getting
two like I would I would love to have
him as part of my Blitz package yes like
he's he's that good he can do that Nick
Hampton from Appalachian State is off
the board now to the Rams listen I love
me some Appalachian State guys Nick
Hampton this is someone who the way he
played was he just consistently was
disruptive and I think that's the key
here obviously you look at the
measurables and somebody people are
going to wonder see this is he that he's
six foot two 236 what does he play does
he play The Edge is he a linebacker how
do you use him I think the key here is
finding someone that you can use using
all past in past situations and then you
have to figure out is he going to be an
actual linebacker or is he going to be
just a situational education so him and
Byron young are not too dissimilar to me
as prospects they drafted Byron young
obviously in the third round to the
Tennessee Edge rusher and that both are
just pure explosiveness pure effort do
we know what we're doing
do we have a lot of pass rushing moves
or are we you know gonna play the run at
a high level because I'm 236 pounds here
Nick Hampton no you're just not that's
not what you're getting but the ramps
have consistently not necessarily cared
about that in their Edge guys they want
Edge guys that bring juice off the edge
right that if they're one-on-one because
everyone's got to worry and kind of
pinching down your guards do on Aaron
Donald well if you give them space these
guys can get to the quarterback that's
how I feel about Hampton he's probably
more of a DPR your situational pass
rusher uh third down guy but the effort
dude I mean he comes into contact like
he's the bigger dude every time but he's
236 pounds you don't see a lot of 236
pounders whose key move is bull rush
Nick Hampton is yeah so I'm a fan of his
tape I do just worry about how those
traits are going to translate to the NFL
and if he is ever going to be anything
more than a DPR but man in this
situation I'm cool with it I I like what
they did here at this point in the draft
yeah same I'm listen App State great
football tradition great football
heritage
they put guys into the NFL they do what
they like they they know what they're up
to they know what they're up against and
they they go out there and they they put
together pretty consistently so this is
good I know he was never gonna coming
out of that he was never gonna have the
size that someone from Alabama or
Georgia had so they found a way to use
them really really well and so we'll see
if he's able to translate those skills
in the next time I do Wonder because he
has a big frame I do wonder if he can
put on some more mass right it is six
eight wingspan for being only six two
like the the length is there just can we
in an NFL weight room get him up to
speed that's that if you can tell me you
can get up to 250 with musculature
feel better about it he's a higher pick
than this how about this we're going to
South Beach folks it's will Mallory will
Mallory a tight end from Miami this is a
guy played a lot of football for them he
feels a little undersized a minute tight
end but he's not going to play wide
receiver so you look at this guy six
foot four and a half 239 doesn't look
like he's 239 though because a little
bit more stretched out but when you look
at will Mallory play what you are going
to get is a guy who understands the game
he really understands where he's going
to be open he also knows which matchups
he can win and that's the part where he
takes chances against linebackers takes
chances against some safeties and then
in other situations he sits it down so
me I like this will Mallory pick
especially in this spot because they're
getting the guy in the Colts that's
going to go out there try to help
Anthony Richardson he ran the fastest
four to get the combine of any tight end
in attendance he can really threaten the
seams of your defense and
that's kind of his bread and butter is
Corners posts seam routes he wins on
those fairly consistently and will run
away from linebackers the problem is
it's not really bigger than a lot of
linebackers number 39 the dude is skinny
and especially his legs if you're
putting him as an inline blocker he will
get exposed I I just find it hard to
believe he's going to be able to put on
the requisite Mass to ever Block in line
and he really didn't have kind of the
mentality that you would want to develop
there but Colts are loading up on
athletes that's been their MO but this
is a guy who is a little something
different than Jelani woods and Moe
alley Cox that you already have in towed
there at the tight end position all
right folks we've got another pit coming
in right here this is another this guy I
love is Chase Brown Chase Brown out of
Illinois Speedy guy he's finds a way to
he runs tough he runs fast he runs tough
I don't know if he looks much faster
because his legs are so short but he
runs he runs hard and coming out of
Illinois we talked about on the
defensive side talked about the
mentality change with the coaching
change Chase Brown is kind of indicative
of that as well so twin brothers of
Sydney Brown and they are identical and
like build they are both shorter squatty
but Jack to the gills yep both ran mid
four fours and the explosiveness you see
on tape I mean he would not go this late
if it weren't for the funneling problems
five fumbles this past year on 329
carries had a couple more at the Senior
Bowl that's a big No-No you know coaches
have very little patience for guys
putting it on the ground nowadays that's
the problem but like this guy has Bell
cow potential he does not need to come
off the field on Pass Downs does not
need to come off the field uh on third
downs and for this Cincinnati Bengals
who kind of used their running backs as
just like spells so it's just like they
don't have roles there obviously behind
Joe Mixon who has legal issues that he's
fighting this off season this is a guy
that could just be a starter for you at
this point in the draft if you tell me
he's fixing that fumbling problem uh I'm
showing you a starter in the NFL right
now so that's a that's a great pick yeah
Bengals I think both those offensive
dudes they drafted there and him and
Charlie Jones those are guys that make
an impact on the roster this season
yeah I like it was Charlie Jones you
mentioned and they just got Chase Brown
DJ Turner I thought was one of a heck of
a pickup for them Jared Hall to the
Vikings
oh
there he goes they get the QB of the
Future Let's Get Kirk back on the line
hear his thoughts on if jiren Hall is
really the quarterback The Heir Apparent
now I truthfully
I was not high in Joe I'll just say it I
get why there's there's a lot to like
he's a Twitchy athlete he can get out of
tight situations
he has a nice easy quick release and I
thought the Improvement he showed this
past year was very evident from the year
prior but it allowed the same concerns
you have that Zach Wilson had where it's
like he's playing in a BYU offensive so
play action heavy that with such a good
offensive line for his competition level
that look at these Pockets he's
operating from it's seven on seven he is
playing glorified seven on seven he
didn't have to learn good habits he got
a lot of bad habits when it came to how
to handle pressure that I worry about
the NFL level and he's six foot 207. you
know does not have the height of a you
know a developmental project that you
usually take at this point in the draft
so I wasn't as high but he is oh the
last note on him he's 25 years old too
like he's an older guy he actually did
you know the more admission stuff all
that so
um interesting player but
I would have gone elsewhere personally I
think he's I think he is good I think
the thing I like about him is his
accuracy to the corners the thing I
would like to see more of his accuracy
to the interior that's the part for me
and it reminds me it reminds me a little
bit of Sam Howe
um a guy who was very good throwing to
the edges but not so much right over the
interior and obviously that's like a six
foot guy you know that's like the knock
on six foot guys though it's due to
improve there usually know yeah exactly
no that's why I brought him up because
it was the same the same house the same
side yeah he's the same house thicker
than him but they're the same height
yeah
so yeah I just don't know if that's a
thing that's going to happen for him and
that's the thing you have to be able to
do if you're going to make it take that
next step but he's a heck is up a
competitor but an athlete I think he
comes from a family full of athletes and
you see they're on tape like if you want
to run him in the Run game more than
capable of doing so
that's Jaron Hall
interesting like a lot of QBs coming off
the board yeah and I think there's going
to be a few more that come off the board
as well before the draft's over I think
obviously I think Tanner McKee is going
to probably get drafted before this day
is over I think Malik Cunningham could
get drafted Oh nice before is all said
and done I'm trying to think is there
any more guys in this quarterback class
that may be that maybe in terms of guys
that are draftable grades on but we
shall see
biggest in
Terrell Smith hey there we go
he has some fans I'm surprised he lasted
this long because
this isn't a
is this a guy who ticks boxes physically
who has sort of you know six foot over
200 pounds and was really productive on
tape this past year I just think he
wasn't quite as sticky as I would like
from an NFL corner I I think his sort of
hips and the you know lateral agility
That I Want from an outside corner
wasn't there but dude's physical he
really bodies guys he knows how to use
that size to his advantage and he'll
push guys to the sideline consistently
when they try to go past him and he's
got four four one speed there's no oh
you know some of the concerns we're
saying about other guys on tape of oh he
candy hack it at the NFL level with
um with the size jump up with the speed
jump up no those are not issues with him
on tape it's just that he really didn't
put out good tape at Minnesota until
this past season he had it I believe has
been playing there for three years since
his freshman year at Minnesota but
really never the light switch never
turned on until this past season so I'm
going to say this and the Bears they get
two corners that are over
six feet tall I think that says a lot
about the plan that they have and what
they're going to try to do maybe maybe
Charles Smith works out for him maybe he
does it but it's very clear that if
they're going to take a corner they need
him to be tall yeah I I'm interested
because Maddie eberfles
he kind of had Blank Slate right carte
blanche he had nothing on defense you
have like Jalen Johnson right heading it
this year Eddie Jackson and then build
the defense how you want to and it's
interesting to me that with over 100
million dollars in free agency they
prioritize linebacker that's where he
went he said give me Tremaine Edmonds
give me TJ Edwards that's where I want
to start my defense usually
it's either d-line corner is what you
would think but he goes linebacker and
now they're kind of having to fill in
and we're seeing he said DTS was his
next they addressed that rounds two
rounds three or were they both round two
whatever the dress two DTS and now
they're turning their eyes to the corner
of that position trying to grab you guys
there
yeah this is going to be interesting to
see what happens we've still got guys on
the big board we got Taylor McKee we got
travius Hodges Tomlinson we've got Andre
Carter Corey Trice
A.T Perry is still there if somebody's
looking for a wide receiver oh I would
love Corey Trice to the Chiefs yeah
Corey tries to the Chiefs as a
possibility so
this is an interesting one
how many more we got in this third round
we are at pick 166 Kansas State Chiefs
177 is the last pick of the fifth round
Los Angeles Rams we've got the ramps on
the clock three more times in this room
they're just loading up at this point in
the draft that's their bread and butter
because they don't draft highly but they
still draft a lot
is there ml um but yeah we're getting to
the point and we kind of reached that
point right let's be honest where
these are not
we always get I got sugar coated these
are not guys who are started these are
guys who if you get anything from them
you were happy as heck to have gotten it
but these are guys that are
truly you're truly seeing your scouting
Department shine at this point in the
draft though if you get anything from
these guys
so we've got the pick in for the Chiefs
let's see what they get
should we reset some of our favorite
drafts so far v.j Thompson okay another
guy he's a similar mole to Nick Hampton
this is a Stephen F Austin Edge rusher
who's very undersized I think he was
listed
at 2 20 by Stephen F Austin comes to the
Shrine Bowl in the 230s but still like
way too much size to really make an
impact at the NFL level but he is an
absolute high-end athlete I think he uh
broad jump to 11 feet vertical jumped
over 40 like that kind of explosiveness
is what you're dealing with but I mean
he is angular and skinny as can be this
is a pure
if we can get them you know in our
weight room in our developmental program
what could you look like in three years
because productive on tape but low level
competition with a weird body type when
it comes to playing in the NFL yeah I um
here's the thing let's do this we before
we do before we hit the compass the
compensatory picks let's reset this
second round or this fifth this second
the fifth round sorry my brain is fried
um let's reset this fifth round before
we get into the the compensatory picks
um let's see we started out with we
started out with the Jags taking Yasir
Abdullah then we went with the
commanders and KJ Henry we got the Colts
and Darius Rush
um we got Cardinals Clayton toon the
quarterback out of Houston we have the
Browns with DTR quarterback out of UCLA
next up we have the Vikings which are
Kailyn Roy defensive tackle from LSU
guys gonna be a sure run stopper for
them we get the Browns and Cameron
Mitchell a cornerback out of
Northwestern a very smart player very
heads up player and we get the Jets
taking Israel abbeykanda that's
Pittsburgh a Pittsburgh running back
there we go Antonio Mafi UCLA guard
we've got James we got Jamie Robinson
safety from Florida State
Jordan Howden safety from Minnesota Josh
Weil tight end from Cincinnati Noah
Seoul linebacker from Oregon we will see
if he sticks at linebacker moves to Edge
we got Sean Clifford quarterback for to
the Packers from Penn State Bills take
Justin shorter wide receiver from Penn
State in Florida Seahawks Mike Morris uh
defensive end out of Michigan we've got
Lions Colby sort of soul an offensive
tackle from William Mary Slovakia Dennis
linebacker from Pittsburgh to the
Buccaneers Seahawks Olu olawatini
Michigan Center 49ers Daryl luter
cornerback South Alabama Chargers Jordan
McFadden Clemson uh guard Ravens Kai
blue Kelly cornerback from Stanford
Daniel Scott safety from California to
the Colts Packers dontavion Wicks wide
receiver from Virginia Texas A M safety
Antonio Johnson he goes to the Jags Rams
grab Nick Hampton and Edge rusher from
App State the Colts pick up Will Malia
tied in from Miami Bengal goat Chase
Brown
a running back from Illinois Vikings go
jiren Hall quarterback from BYU bears go
Tyrell Smith cornerback from Minnesota
and Chiefs go BJ Thompson
Edge rusher from Stephen F Austin we are
now on to their compensatory picks the
pick is in we've already seen a trade
Rams have traded their pick to the
Houston Texans the pick is in they want
more picks who do we have
what are the Rams gonna do to own the
seventh round here
amazing the Rams turn yep they traded it
up so here we go so some of my favorites
so far of this round yeah I like KJ
Henry to the commander so okay I think
he plays a role there uh I really like
Cameron Mitchell to the Cleveland Browns
I think that was one of the steals of
this round so far Jamie Robinson to the
Panthers I I I don't know if he starts
but he's a guy who I like as a starter
I like Daniel Scott to the Indianapolis
Colts and I love Chase Brown to the
Cincinnati Bengals as well as Trail
Smith the Chicago Bears this is all my
favorites of this Henry toe to oh
linebacker Alabama yep the Texans pick
up Henry tomato he's a linebacker from
Alabama this is a guy that started out
at Tennessee was a highly talented kid
played at Tennessee transferred to
Alabama became their instantly became
their starting uh kind of Mike
linebacker he's seems a little
undersized uh plays at 6-1 227 but he
certainly has a feel and a knack for the
game he knows where he's supposed to be
he's someone that can make himself
skinny and he is skinny when it comes to
being a part of the blitz packages but
he's almost always in the right place at
the right time and he finds ways to make
an impact on the game what do you think
about him yeah so I had him actually
truthful so a lot of people had him in
the top hundred this was a guy that had
a lot of fans I had him right in this
range I I was not they had him
177 on my draft board because physical
too like he wants to get after the play
stylistically is something you love and
obviously pairing him with the mecca
Ryan's like I can see the vision there
with him and I'm excited to see what he
can do and develop into but I do just
think he's lacking as a pure athlete to
really be a playmaker at the next level
and I worry about him in coverage most
specifically I really saw him get lost
in times because of that aggressiveness
because his eyes are so locked in on the
backfield he wants to come downhill he
can be sucked out of position a little
too easily for my money and there you go
like he tracks down Henry hooker there
though if as defense if his other
Defender wasn't there hookers running
back that's the issue I see with him on
tape is that when you're undersized you
better have some juice behind you you
better have some sideline sideline speed
and I just never quite saw that from
toes right yeah but he played in a
system where everything was set up to be
funneled to him which is that's what
you're supposed to do that's the whole
point of playing linebacker and having
defensive ends and having outside
contain linebacker makes the play going
away here we go we got another pick ooh
Papa okay oh the Auburn let's go I love
this pick Owen Papo you want to talk
about sideline the sideline speed this
kid is fast he can absolutely fly I love
his game he reminds me a lot of a more
aggressive more violent Alec Ogletree in
terms of the way that he plays the game
Ogletree always came off as more of a
passive linebacker tackle guys from the
side Pappa wants to tackle you going
downhill look at him in coverage he's
going to be aggressive little handsy but
he's going to be there he is super
talented this kid has been a star since
he was in eighth grade No Lie first time
I ever saw him eighth grade in Atlanta
he ran a 4 4 40 at the Nike camp and
they just kept being the best player he
was he's the only person he invited
three times to the opening that's insane
that doesn't happen usually like like a
guy like Marco Parsons yeah he went one
time oh and papo's been three times this
guy can play didn't have a great he I
doubt he was good at Auburn I think he
got a little over aggressive at times I
think he got over his skis sometimes
he's got to harness that speed which is
tough to do for a young guy but I love
him I love Owen Papo this guy is
an elite elite athlete yeah what we said
about like Trenton Simpson yesterday I
think Simpson's like built better for
linebacker this guy on tape plays yeah I
mean 439 speed 29 bench press reps you
see it yeah you see that ability and I
thought he improved mightily as a
tackler this past season yeah a lot of
that like over aggressiveness that we
saw earliest career was came as a
tackler and he would just overrun and be
complete opposition you saw him play a
little bit more under control it still
is an issue but I love that you at least
saw Improvement I do still think that
when you watch his tape you see every
decision going on in his head like
everything
and then it's like this happened I go
here this happened I go there it's very
by the book that kind of limits that
athletic tools like you don't see it
enough but it's there and I love the
Improvement and if you're the Arizona
Cardinals and you desperately need help
anywhere along this roster I love their
vision for how they've approached this
draft it's guys that this year aren't
going to make an impact own Papa's not
going to make an impact for this year
he's not starring for your roster guys
like John Gaines aren't starting for you
guys like Garrett Williams the
cornerback coming off an ACL aren't
starting for you but what they can be if
you get them in the fold and if you
develop these guys are all good good
players for your football team so I
think the Arizona Cardinals have had a
very good draft in my opinion even if
they're you know the Paris Johnson pick
might have been a little early for me
the fact that they traded got some draft
Capital got a future first rounder and
still got a Paris Johnson very hard to
argue with how this draft has been
approached post Steve Chimera oh wow I
seen Richards from UNC um offensive
tackle this is a guy that when you look
at and play Hey you they he helped
protect Drake May and that was that's
your main job right
and he's a tackle guard convert in my
opinion yeah you know he's six foot four
309 34-inch arms but to me he just
struck me foot speed wise as a guard you
know nothing physically about him from a
build perspective screams that he has to
kick inside but just I did not love him
mirroring speed uh thought he had some
balance issues when he was asked to do
so but a lot of times you know playing
out in space is just it is so different
and I think he's a guy that on the
interior a lot of the things that
plagued him a lot of the reasons why
maybe he you know he allowed 20
pressures this past season I think those
get alleviated I think he's going to be
much better and he's a three-year
starter experienced dude and he now goes
to a spot in Dallas that the track
record of development there is strong he
has a lot of good guys to learn from in
that fold so fifth round that's kind of
where I had him on my board so solid
pick
boom there we go I I man that's the hoco
pick I love yeah I love what they did to
their d-line here in this draft I think
they've got an impact with not a lot of
draft Capital they got guys that can
actually play for your roster this
season
Dan there okay well the Jets looks like
they've traded the pick
no one wants picks to the Raiders no one
wants to draft any of these guys
apparently
we haven't really been keeping up on
trades has there been a lot of movement
for future picks I'd be curious because
everyone's saying this draft from not
great and I think the consensus was this
wasn't a talented or super deep draft
that's how you see kickers going in the
third round I'd be curious to see how
many people actually gave up you know a
future third a future fourth because
obviously you'd like that in a week
draft class so I'm going to give it to
you but it's easier said than done to
get so
nope
there we go the Jets send 170 to Raiders
for 204 and 220.
so they're just trading backwards in
this same draft yeah okay so no future
picks so they're gonna get two guys that
I love it their hands on the clock three
more times is there uh hilarious but the
Raiders draft we've talked about a
little here I just I don't see it's just
com it's how it's putting them over the
hump right it is it's if you're the Las
Vegas Raiders
you have to look yourself in the mirror
and say
I'm in a division with Patrick Holmes
and Justin Herbert for
the foreseeable future
how do I beat those guys what what takes
me there to me a Byron young doesn't
take it you know stop on the run a
little doesn't take me there I I would
have liked a little more swings than
what they took yeah like Trey Tucker is
a Return Man Byron Young's a two Gap
defensive tackle
mayor I'm not gonna complain about
that's a great solid tight end but like
the whole point for them is do you
either have to get really good corners
in safeties or really good Edge washers
that's how you beat those two players
that's how you beat them yeah yeah
they're like even like an Aiden
O'Connell and I get we're at a point
where it's like you're not getting much
but
backup quarterback's not the difference
between you and the championship right
yeah that's not what you're not losing
because you're not close unfortunately
so I don't know I'm just I'm spitballing
and we're at a point in the draft though
where
also
teams pigeonhole themselves into picks
early on they're like play the board
play the board now they're like hey I
need this you know we don't have a
foreign we don't have a corner that with
special teams versatility now we have to
go draft the top one on our board that
sort of thing
oh here Christopher Smith Georgia safety
yeah
he was a guy who on tape
I liked more than his testing I thought
he was a guy that could play from a too
high or single high alignment he's 510
192 like he had some range I thought and
he makes plays like that in the Oregon
game and other plays on his tape where
it's like he got there in a hurry and I
think he sees the game really well but
he goes to the combine runs a 4-6-2 with
a 33 inch vertical at his Pro Day At A
7453 Cone and a 441 shuttle just a low
tier athlete that's why he drops this
point in the draft
because I had him as a borderline top
100 player before that but I'm not sure
you just want to go to bat for a guy
who's that limited athletic and there he
is wrapping up Jalen high in space so
maybe maybe you could throw that testing
out the window but like plays like that
where he just triggers goes hits it I
was a fan of the way he played but again
undersized poor athlete that's how a guy
falls to this point in the draft who
maybe has a little bit better tape like
a Christopher Smith here's what I'm
going to say you said you said it
perfectly
you love the way he sees the game he
sees the game very well so what does
that allow him to do anticipate
it allows you to anticipate things he
studies film very clearly he studies
film he knows what's going to happen
before it happens so you can't do
anything to him that he's not going to
expect the only time that did happen the
SEC Championship game
Jamison Williams coming on a bunch
he's like I know what Alabama does on
this play and then Alabama had him break
it across the field
he couldn't recover because he didn't
have the speed
touchdown game change all right what do
we get so for a guy who projects as a
deep safety to not have that deep range
is scary mm-hmm
no trade okay another trade
is insane all right so oh come on and
guys we're so close why just do do just
pick
uh so of
let's see this pick just got traded one
two three
the last eight picks all but two
were trade traded away multiple times I
I honestly have never seen anything like
this
over the majority of picks have been
traded in this round
that's
that's I think that's very indicative of
how the NFL sees yeah this class
man I I do so Andre Carter we may not
get to talk about him because he may not
go here but I want to talk about him the
Army Edge rusher yeah
let's see you will get drafted you know
his tape was good enough to get drafted
yeah but he is in one of the weirdest
prospects and the weirdest Prospect
profiles because he's coming from army
right he's coming from a school where
you are not training to play football
year round you are training to be in the
Army you know which is vastly different
type of training and so when he goes to
the his pro day
at 66 256 with three four inch arms and
runs a four nine one forty with only a
30 inch vertical and 9-1 broad jump and
11 bench press reps which I don't know
why he even stood under that bench
knowing he was going to do like you
don't just accidentally do 11 when I was
like oh I'm doing 20 all week no he knew
he was going to do 11. that's
that tells me he just has not had the
development physically that these other
guys have right and that but then like
you flip on the tape and that's the only
thing missing from his game the guy uses
his hands really well he's creative he
has incredible Bend for a six foot six
dude he had a six nine seven three cone
even without the high-end athletic
training that we're talking about in a
429 short shuttle which are Elite
numbers of the position so he has the
way to play the game he has the sort of
traits that are difficult to improve
upon in a weight room that is agility
all he needs is the play strength and
explosiveness how much can he add can
you add 15 pounds of muscle to his frame
if you tell me he can this guy will be a
starter in the NFL and a high-end star
in the NFL so a weird Prospect profile
he had 15 and a half sacks two years ago
before everyone found out who he was and
started doubling them I don't know this
is where I'm taking a chance on this guy
though I'm taking a chance on him before
some of these other guys that have come
off the board for sure like a BJ
Thompson
who they have that explosiveness but
they don't know what the heck they're
doing I think the guy who knows what the
heck he's doing and has a reason why I
can coach some explosiveness into him
that's who I'm going to take so that's
why I'm high in them that's why he's
high on the board but also why he's
available at this point in the draft
sure pain Durham is the pick for the
bucks to get a tight end
um that was productive at Purdue 58
catches last year uh 56 excuse me 560
yards 10 yards per cash that's pretty
easy math even I can do it
um eight eight touchdowns so he was
their second go-to guy behind Charlie uh
Charlie Jones good good ball player I
don't need him to be doing very much
blocking if we're being quite honest but
he's a guy that's going to catch patches
catch passes he seems I would would you
rather have him or will Mallory
that's a good question so he's more
reliable Mallory's for they're like Ops
ends of the spectrum right like this guy
you can count on to haul it in wherever
it's thrown to him he's going to catch
him underneath intermediate whatever but
he's not going to run away from anybody
I think he went 487 at the combine
that's you know capped off where's
Mallory is 454. he's gonna make me work
with that so it depends on what you want
I'd probably go paint Durham though I
just don't see it with Mallory I think
he's too much of a liability as a
blocker to even see the feel whereas
pain Durham can see the field for me so
we got Eric gray Eric gray goes to the
Giants at pick 37 uh 172 overall Eric
Gray's a guy that I like I like the one
of the Tennessee obviously Tennessee
have that sort of a mini Mass Exodus
with Wanya with um obviously with Eric
gray leaving out as well so what you end
up with is a guy Eric gray who is a very
good running back came in highly touted
to Tennessee I think he's Shifty I think
he has the ability to make plays in The
Run game man in the past game and he did
pretty well at Oklahoma's I love his
vision and his patience those are two
things that you cannot teach people
vision and patience there's too many
guys that run up their law their
offensive lineman's backs but you look
at him right here okay look at that I'm
quick I'm Shifty I can go basically and
I'm explosive and I can way stops right
there good great my ACL will be all the
way in it would be in Texas by then do
I'm surprised this guy lasts this long
he's a good pass catcher I think that's
a good pass blocker yeah this is your
third down back you know you obviously
have saquon Barkley who you know maybe
he's gonna hold out maybe he's not going
to whatever but you don't want to
subject saquon Barkley to the hits and
pass Pro that this guy can go take you
know he can be your third down guy when
you want to give saquan a spell and be
super reliable he's got great hands yep
he's Shifty like you mentioned and maybe
he's not super explosive the way sequan
is but he can get apple right in tight
spaces you know he can be
the number two there in a pretty number
two that you feel good about so at this
point in the draft like I said a
surprise you last this long I really
like what the Giants have done yeah
that's a that's a pick for pick good
good good draft no one I'm questioning
none of those picks none of those fits
none of those values that's perfect
that's how you want your draft to look
like when you don't have the draft
Capital that some others in Boston
this is good okay we got the 49ers have
got their pick in
not giving Daniel Jones any excuses
there yeah prove it we gave you the
money
show their Farm guide the rims now we're
three of the last four three of the last
four thank you there's nowhere for them
to go they can't trade anymore
yeah well there's two more rounds don't
uh
don't speak too soon here but no
they're gonna end up trading into a spot
they traded out of at some point you
know it's gonna happen
they're
oh
they're just moving so much all right
49ers dude this 49ers draft
can we just like discuss it a little bit
again I think yeah let's go ready here
we go 49ers but it was I mean when you
don't pick until 99 initially it's gonna
be weird yeah but the 49ers have they
put together jair Brown
safety from Penn State Jake Moody the
kicker that was wild
I don't understand that still Cameron
late to the Titan from Alabama Daryl
luter from South Alabama and their way
the pick is in we're waiting on their
pick
but they're they're in a position where
I wonder what they do with this Lance
and
Purdy thing right because Lance has to
play football you draft him where they
drafted him right
and Anthony Richardson is going to be
the same conversation this year he's got
to see the field for the 49ers or for
someone else for anyone like to to get
better because he has
over the course of his high school
Collegiate and NFL career had fewer
drawbacks than Tom Brady did this
passing that's that's insane the guy
needs to play football we talked about
that with DTR right yeah you have to get
reps dad you're not you can't get better
you saw how much DTR yeah mental reps
are they only take you so far and so
when you draft them third knowing that
knowing he had one season of college
football under his Bell like you had to
give him leeway and I get that you were
in a championship window and it was like
oh we're so close right now you go to
the you know you go to the NFC
Championship Game the next year maybe it
changes the math a little bit but
why take the biggest project in that
draft
if you did think you were that close I I
don't it's there was a disconnect
somewhere and at some point in my
opinion you just got to bite the bullet
and turn the keys over to this guy
whether it's for a full season or if
it's like an eight-game trial he has to
get that at some point and obviously no
one expected him to get injured this
past season but I don't think you know
Brock was great don't get me wrong Brock
looked awesome last year but you have to
turn it over to Trey Lance at some point
this season
know what you got give him that time and
then if if it doesn't work out and
you're still in the hunt nfc's weak
enough Brock can maybe save you at the
end but man they got to give him that
chance all right here we go
the pick is in
it is Robert Beale Jr
defensive end linebacker from Georgia
Robert Beale from Georgia There It Is
big time player when his number got
called he was able to make plays I
really I've liked him since high school
this is someone when you watch him play
you can see some aggression you could
see some energy he was kind of buried
behind a bunch of other guys but he is
someone for me
um if we're talking kind of player he
reminds me a little bit of Kevin green
right the old Steelers and Panthers a
guy that if he beefs it up a little bit
he's going to be a true Like Elephant in
that in that 3-4 scheme he's very
violent with his hands he wants to win
he wants to walk you back he can use
speed off the edge this guy is a creeper
that just makes plays like I think the
really look at that come on
and I just think that he's got an
opportunity he just didn't get as many
of those opportunities at Georgia
because they had Jordan Davis
they had
well what was his face he was that guy
Clay Walker and they had Nolan Smith and
they like they had all these guys who
was the one who was the best one Trayvon
Walker no no the one who ended up having
legal issues and then oh um I was nuts
and then yeah I can't remember yeah but
but behind him too
and so he's got great potential Big Time
potential I love him coming off the edge
I love what he's able to do when his
number did get called this year which it
did because Nolan Smith went down he
rose to the occasion yeah and four four
eight forty you have maybe the best
d-line coach in the NFL Chris corsic
their in tow they obviously this is the
guy with developmental potential when
you have nearly 35 inch arms with 448
speed
that's something you want to work with
and Georgia for as much as you know
they've produced Talent I'm not sure
they've developed Talent along that
defensive line like we're talking about
Trayvon Walker as a project we're
talking about uh Nolan Smith having to
develop more pass rushing moves because
they emphasize scheme so much there they
are play as a unit play as a unit play
as a unit and so guys don't necessarily
get the skill development that say maybe
like in Ohio state is known for so I I
do think there is some meat on the bone
here for this pick but obviously like
it's just purely a coin toss at a guy
who's a high high-end athlete yes
as he has has always been looking
forward I'm glad he got his shot like
I'm not glad Noah Smith got hurt but I'm
glad he got his opportunity because he
waited in the wings a long time as a guy
that was fully capable
kind of reminds me of being in a similar
position to Byron young at Alabama who
did play he played all the time but it
started a bunch of games last year his
last year is when he came alive when
they really needed him to oh here we go
Warren McLendon back-to-back dogs coming
off the court right opposite ends of the
Spectrum in terms of prospects we have
the high-end athlete yes project and we
have the well-oiled machine a tackle who
just doesn't quite have the physical
Gifts of his tacklemate Roger Jones like
he was more effective in pass protection
this past season than brought to jump
yes but he is stiff he is not super
explosive as an athlete not super Nimble
but he uses his lengths really well 34.5
inch arms this is a perfect swing tackle
that you probably won't complain about
if you have to say you know say Joseph
no boom goes down yet again this guy can
plug in there and won't look out of
place so this is this is the guy who may
never start in the league but he's a guy
who can stay on a roster for a while
yeah he's good he knows what he's doing
and I think that's the key here is he
knows what he's doing he doesn't make
bad he doesn't take bad steps he creates
creases for his running backs and then
he just is excited enough to run down
there and try to make plays yeah he
loves to see it no pre-draft workout for
him but
was not going to be great he's just he's
limited athletically why he falls this
point draft despite being multi-year
start he was starting over Broderick
Jones actually like 2021 that team he
was the right tackle Broderick Jones is
the guy who's kind of
um coming in when Jamar salyer had to
kick inside he came in then but Warren
McClendon was starting over him that
season
how many more we got here only three
more with the Rams pick being in right
now we got the Colts and then the Rams
yet again to end it on what was
a somewhat team
day three I'll say yeah but a lot of QBs
a lot of QB is coming off the board I
mean tame is a word tame is interesting
because we've seen so much action but
none of it's really meant anything yeah
I just feel like there's no like really
off the wall not too many really off the
wall names kind of all guys you're like
this is yeah this is about where you
should sit at the range this is the
range I guess there is the two guys that
I truly had not watched the William and
Mary tackle land for the Minnesota
safety so yeah getting to that point it
happens
I do have you ever did you have you ever
done seven rounds of your life yes seven
rounds gets fun it gets it's fun as a
word it's
um you feel like you're drunk by the end
of seven rounds absolutely of talking
about every single pick are you trying
to know different things to say and
every single year oh man so do we get to
see any of these guys come off the board
we got three picks all right let's see
Rams would not surprise me if they win
Travis Hodge Tomlinson they're one of
the teams that I think would draft him
they obviously love Darius Williams when
he was there undersized Corner in that
scheme could be possible I'm trying to
think who else on the board there
um whose tops available
I'd love to see Deuce Fawn come off the
board here I know it's Allen
oh another tight end Clemson okay
he's he's the perfect number two Titan
Davis Allison is a great number two
Titan you see him here at Clemson this
is a guy that finds ways to get open can
catch the ball in traffic the other
thing I like about his game though is
he's improved he's improved tremendously
from where he was a year ago and what I
mean by that is he's been able to work
better in blocking yes his blocking was
atrocious a year ago and now it's
getting better he's working to find ways
to get open but also to Stone people
he's working how to do better against
tight ends working how to move out
safeties working how to get to
linebackers the best thing that he does
obviously is make contested catches oh
yeah use his body he boxes out like a
basketball player which is what
everybody wants to see happen but the
real the real key for me is how he's
able to improve his blocking and he said
he's a great number two Titan yes
perfect number two tight end because not
fast we're at 484 at the combine just
never gonna stretch the field vertically
but Ultra reliable probably the best
ball skills in this class
he's so good in contest situations and
he can kind of go up and get it yeah 38
and a half inch vertical that's it
aspect to his game that in the Red Zone
you want to throw him some back
shoulders you want to throw them a
little jump balls he can be productive
in that regard and they did that at
Clemson quite a bit so I'm a fan in that
kind of role and again
receiving ability with some blocking
ability at this point the draft I had
him ahead of a number of tight ends that
already come off the board and I think
it's a good player this is why the Rams
load up on these picks right is because
this guy can play a role they're getting
a lot of guys that
you know maybe they're not going to be
elite starters but you don't have
liabilities then on your football field
when you have guys like Davis Allen
things are tight end too yeah you don't
have to worry about them he's going to
get the job done is he going to do it to
the level of some Superstar no but you
know what the job will still get done
you got Tyler pick me you know you gotta
you got a guy who is that receiving
first tight end on the roster you don't
need two of them it's difficult to find
roles when you have two of them this
this should go quick the Colts pick is
in in the Rams are on the clock they
should be done the Rams should already
have their pick done I love that you're
like ramps just figure it out you've
been on the clock for the last three
picks yeah they've been on yeah they've
been on clock for three of the last four
picks they've been on the clock
uh
uh you come up with two guys if they
take the guy you want you take the other
guy
all right Colts
Man Who Would we want for the call so
the Colts are going to draft an elite
athlete don't get it twisted that's okay
can we see the big board then so then
who would be who would fit that of who's
still available on the draft board
um right the Corey Trice would fit that
Court tries to highlight okay of those
guys I would not say anyone else would
be a testing athlete that they would
want I think we're gonna have to drop
down a little bit you know who hasn't
come off the board keshan bhute hasn't
come off the board yet well he's weak
listen we can talk about him right now
he's got a lot of issues yeah like he's
a guy that basically seemed like he quit
to start this season
and then realize oh my draft stock can
fall I need to start playing like he it
was bananas to watch how how much he
disappeared wasn't there was not just I
don't know it was it was it was insane
like I'm gonna I gotta I gotta look it
up now here's a player that could fit
there
Trey Palmer from Nebraska could fit the
Colts he's a super athlete dude's a
super athlete that that could be the
pick we're that's the name Sean Tucker
could be it should be could be a fit
here too that's a super athlete through
the first one two three
four games through the first four games
he had
11 catches
he was not even trying and it did not
and then one did not play yeah
and then after that six six four seven
four four six
including two 100 yard games
he just like he's like I'll just turn it
on at the end oh here we go here's a
good pick Evan Hall Northwestern running
back this is your nahim Heinz
replacement
Evan hole Northwestern running back this
guy
he you know they say some people make it
look easy he made it look hard but he
did it you know what I'm saying like yes
there's a lot of effort coming out of
his corner but he got the job done so
for me I think this is a great pick go
ahead and tell tell the folks what
they're getting he's appear receiving
back I don't think he's your it's your
compliment to Jonathan Taylor right like
they trade away and Heinz last year this
is a guy that can fill that role it ran
a four four seven
um he's a jump cut King he kind of just
slaloms as his running style yep and he
ran behind some right he ran behind
an offensive line that outside of pios
karonski could not open up holes for him
and so you like guys that did that that
had to overcome consistently and this is
going to be it's going to be your out of
the backfield option routes that sort of
thing third down back it needs to
improve his pass protection I'll say
that that's the one area where kind of
dichotomous with him where you would
love it if he was better in that regard
so that he could see the football field
more but as a pure receiver he can get
the job done so I what I would what if
what if Indianapolis implemented some of
that like that that claw fence that
Northwestern kind of took to as well
that slow that slow read oh with
Angelina Richardson in whole now and he
can get to his jump cuts and get to
those things that's what Northwestern
they took that from Wake Forest yeah
that's slow that claw fence so he can do
I think that he would work and because
Richardson is always a threat now you do
put those linebackers in a bind and now
you have some problems I'm very curious
to see if any of that makes its way in I
know he's Jeff he's definitely can catch
the ball out of the backfield so this is
going to be pretty interesting to see
how it fixes okay we got our last pick
last pick said let's go ahead and do it
puka
here we go I'm ready to rock and roll on
this one
the pick is in all right who do we have
show me puka nakua BYU this kid coming
out of high school super highly touted
from Utah if I'm not mistaken so I'm
watching I think it's from Utah this is
a guy that people thought was going to
go to Oregon thought I was going to go
to Washington
um ends up at
um BYU he can catch the ball he catches
through he plays through contact
exceptionally well he wants the ball all
the time he wants to go up and get the
football he is someone that led them in
yeah he went to Washington that's what I
thought went played two seasons at
Washington that played the last two at
BYU this guy good change of Direction
good speed listen he's been killing it
since high school a guy that transferred
to BYU from Washington and showed while
he was at Washington to begin with he
was better than just about everybody
else that they played man I wanted to
like this kid I think he does the little
things about playing wide receiver so
well he's got good size he's six foot
once you know in the 6162 range 210
pounds
but it's just such a limited athlete to
where I was washing them on tape and he
let guys back in like he would win off
the line or win on his break and then he
just doesn't have the gas doesn't have
the accelerator to make guys pay when he
does win with his you know probably
above average route running ability
above average hands above average ball
skills a lot of like the things that are
tough to coach into wide receivers he
does really really well
but the thing that's a possibly coach
into dudes which is athleticism he
really is lacking yeah great route
Runner can create separation the ball
needs to be there is the big thing the
ball needs to be there now you need to
be throwing it when he's already taking
that step yes and that wasn't really
happening uh with Jared Hall so we're
going to see um I know what we're gonna
do that's the last end of the fifth
round folks there's we're going to start
the six we are not starting the six
we're gonna say goodbye but first what's
your favorite pick of this of the last
of this day favorite pick of the entire
day oh you really put me on the spot
there there are a few that I liked but I
do think that my favorite one was right
off the top
um I I really liked let me let me go
back and look
what was the one right off top of the
fourth round that I like KJ Henry no yes
sir Abdullah it was Oh wrong one's in
the fifth round that was that was insane
that was insane value this guy truly is
an all-time athlete like Trayvon Walker
levels of athlete that you don't find
four four nine forty thirty seven inch
vertical 282 pounds the guy is jacked
explosive
long
played out of position you could see him
excelling inside more than he did
outside at Northwestern
and that 110 and maybe he has some
degenerative knee issue or maybe he has
something that none of us know about
right now that drops them that far try
truthfully has to with how he was viewed
by everyone that I've talked to that I
trust in their evaluation process was a
lot higher on him than 110. so
if he's healthy though and on a football
field
Colt's got one of the seals to drop
there well for me
um
I was going to say DTR and then I
remembered that oh and Papo got drafted
Owen Papo is a guy that I've just kind
of been watching since he was again
rising out of middle school this guy can
play I'm excited to see him kind of slow
down just a little bit but then use that
speed to play to make make things happen
so I'm looking forward to watching him
with the Cardinals Owen Papo from Auburn
folks thank you so much for tuning in to
BR uh Gridiron draft night this has been
so much fun I hope you learned something
I hope we helped you out I hope you had
a good time folks we are going to get
out of here
for Mike Renner I'm Michael Felder
for the crew the team in the back we're
out peace
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]